Go see a boxing match.
He doesn't even want that to be the
three,
two,
one.
We live.
Are we live?
Yeah.
We were just talking about a sober
October and a red sphere and the
speculation that he may be in fact a
doing,
running some shenanigans.
We do not know.
It seems to be shenanigans at play here,
but he's.
He went to strong the first day.
I know still.
I don't believe that you could sustain
that amount of that heart rate for that.
It's interesting to look at his graph
because he was at 80 plus percent of his
max heart rate for more than an hour and
20 minutes.
Which a look,
he might just be trying to kill himself.
He's got a strong will.
Yes.
I know.
Shifty.
She hung.
Is He shifty and honest because he'll
eventually come out with this is what I
did and of course I did that.
You guys knew I was doing it the whole
time.
That's what he'll say.
Oh,
come on.
Yeah,
of course.
Of course.
I was going to do that.
So yeah.
But he is shifty and like he,
he,
he's a prankster,
he's definitely going to do some weird
stuff to get ahead in this.
But he also knows he's gonna lose to
legion of skanks,
no shit in a box and brought it onto the
stage and he had it like sealed up and
then open it in front of everybody.
And apparently the smile was so
horrendous.
People were bail you out of the room.
He's gagging and throwing up.
It's like a public health hazard.
You're not supposed to like have shit
human shit in public.
He's so weird.
Fast.
And Elisa was gangs.
They've seen everything for them to be
running out of the room.
Yeah,
they've done everything and seeing
everything in red still freaked them
out.
I can't believe that.
I just now heard that story like that
should be like a headline that's shit in
a box and brought it into a room where
the live podcast was taking place.
It was a small room to room with a
hundred people in it.
I love it.
I love someone who is not scared to talk
about shit and deal with shit.
Just
no,
he's not scared of that.
I mean,
look,
the fact that he entered into this
contest at all and it doesn't work out
at all for 10 years,
and then he's like,
there's a fitness contest and the loser
has to do something.
We haven't totally determined what the
loser has to do or he wants us to like
drink each other's piss.
He wants to drink.
Your pis are lifted.
He might not lose right now.
Tom Seger is in the bottom.
Thompson goes at the bottom.
I think tom is gonna try.
I think.
I mean your obviously set to witness
thing,
but I think Tom's going sneak up.
He's playing it down.
You looked at his wrist yesterday.
You Go,
what's the thousand something?
Oh,
that's nothing.
Just the calories you burned that day.
A thousand.
Tom's Tom Sneaky.
A lot of people feel like that.
I really think he's gonna.
He's gonna do something on this.
He's going to be the one to beat.
You got to realize though,
Bert ran a marathon.
He did run a marathon.
He's got this.
This is fun.
I have to say any one of you could pull
ahead,
but you're the.
I mean,
can we talk about what you did
yesterday?
Yeah.
I worked out for three hours and 20
minutes.
I'm trying to.
I'm trying to double marathon.
Yeah.
I'm trying to break burt's will.
That's what I'm really trying to do.
Talks on this Mickey Mantle Gene Shit.
I'm like,
motherfucker,
I'm crazy.
You don't understand.
I will work out twice a day like that.
I will.
I'll try to give you a fucking heart
attack.
You Fat.
Fuck.
I would love to see you will too.
He'll,
you'll kill him.
You couldn't kill it.
Don't know if he's going to.
I don't know how long he's going to keep
it up because like birds,
very competitive up to a point like the.
With the weight loss challenge.
Tom Stayed steady and Tom one in the end
in one bit per tried.
He tried to sprint towards the end but
it was too little too late and Thomas
talking shit the entire time.
Like,
I know what you're gonna do.
You're gonna fuck off until the very
end.
Then you get to try to catch up,
but it's going to be too late.
And he was right.
Yup.
Yeah.
Bert,
I don't know if birds will,
can be broken,
hasn't been broken before.
Uh,
well it's not as will.
It's the discipline aspect.
See,
when you're dealing with an entire
month,
you have 31 days of having to get after
it.
So how often do you get after it
normally?
See,
that's the thing.
Yeah.
The difference between me and Bert is I
work out almost every day already.
So for me it's just like those days off
don't exist anymore.
So what I've decided to do on my days
off,
it's just do shit that I wouldn't
normally do.
So I'll do the elliptical machine for
two hours or I'll do something else or
just I'll do something else,
but the whole time I'm thinking I'm
going to break.
I'm gonna break.
Fuck your Mickey Mantle Gene.
Yeah.
You guys were talking about like who you
think about when you're really trying to
get past that point where you're either
your kickboxing or even on an
elliptical,
sometimes you've got to get angry and
you think of Bert right now
talking about right now I'm thinking of
Bert,
thinking of her breaking bird breaking
as well.
I don't understand.
You guys are all addicts in different
ways and this is so interesting to watch
because you're right.
You already work out a lot.
You're an extremely healthy guy,
but you're now going to take it.
Your Ex.
I can see the excitement on all of you
to take this to just an excruciating
level because it.
It gets obsessive and it gets fun.
Like you can work,
but that's the thing I'm excited to talk
to you at the beginning of this when
you're still pumped up about it and it's
like you get a high from working out for
three and half hours a day.
Seventeen days from now I'm going to be
a beaten man.
Yeah,
you are,
and you're going to get a surge at the
end when it gets close again,
but 17 days.
You're right.
That's not going to be a fun day for
you.
Um,
yeah.
Well,
I don't know.
Who knows,
you know,
did she ever see.
There's a really interesting documentary
with Eddie Izzard.
Eddie Izzard,
who is not a guy,
and really good.
Should you see it?
I didn't it,
but I know what he's done.
I love that guy.
He's so impressive.
He's amazing.
What he did was he ran around Europe.
He did a marathon a day with no
training.
I mean,
no training.
He wasn't,
he wasn't in shape.
He was overweight,
his feet weren't prepared,
his feet got destroyed and I watched
this in the beginning.
I watched us like,
how is he going to do this?
And then towards the end I was like,
wow,
this guy is a force of will.
Just sheer will.
I mean his lifestyle is not that he's
exercising consistently and this is
just,
he's just going to do a little bit more
and really push himself hard.
No,
no exercise,
just like,
I don't think he exercised at all or if
he did it was just,
he just had a normal body,
you know,
it didn't have a body of,
yeah,
somebody's looking at me go a marathon a
day.
Anyone could do that.
But it's,
it's so mental,
mental.
Yeah.
And I think I think a lot of comedians
have that.
Maybe I'm just doing the thing what
comedians do of patting themselves on
the back for being more interesting than
other people.
Like we do all the time.
Like we're so much more broken and we
have more willpower,
but I think that there's.
I get obsessed with exercise too and I
really get into it and I kind of.
I remember Louis C k doing some
interview where he said that he runs
five miles a day because on that fourth
mile when he doesn't want to do the
fifth,
he thinks about like a day where he'll
be on set and want to just call it a day
and not push through and it's like how
it all relates.
Or you'll be in the middle of an hour
set and you'll be tired and you just.
Everything can relate to being on set or
in the middle of a set and that run five
miles a day.
Making yourself do that means you can
get through anything.
And so I run a lot and I have,
I think of it the same way.
It's just endurance to perform for an
hour every night.
Think that's insane that we do that.
Well.
If you have more energy,
definitely can put out more during the
show.
So if you are in better shape,
you have more cardio,
you won't get exhausted,
you'll be able to put out more energy,
you'll be more vibrant,
more robust,
you know,
you,
you really kind of.
I mean in some ways if you're doing like
an hour a night,
especially if you're doing two shows a
night,
right?
You owe it to yourself to have an energy
reserve.
Yeah.
It's just the.
I just think that running,
running so monotonous,
and there's so many times where you
could go,
I could just not do this and I can just
start walking and who cares?
But something about pushing yourself
through a run when you could give up and
always you never regret it.
I'll say that you never regret keeping
running when you could just walk
a moving meditation and a lot of ways
you're.
You're forcing your mind to take control
of your body and you're forcing your
mind to ignore all of the aches and
pains and all the,
the desire to quit.
That's when people say that run
marathons.
You know that you just have to.
Like my friend John Joseph says it best.
He said,
you got to tell you your mind as to tell
your body who the
fuck the bosses
God it is.
I just did dancing with the stars.
Holy Shit.
I just got eliminated last week.
That's a lot of work.
It was so physically exhausting for.
It was a month of my life every day for
hours a day dancing.
And I've never danced before.
And um,
but it was,
I didn't realize how mental it all
really is,
like athletics is,
it's so mental.
I didn't realize it because I've never
been an athlete my whole life.
But before I got into this competition I
was like reading all the books about
like why I am where I am physically
that's not going to change.
So I better figure out a way to mentally
overcome some stuff and I was able to.
But man,
it is,
it's all that I,
I feel like a lot of times and it broke
me in many ways mentally and physically.
But it was,
I mean it was my sober October for sure.
It was my,
you working on every single day and
giving it,
trying to beat Bert.
It's definitely not easy.
There's nothing,
there's nothing.
I did a bunch of dancing lessons for a
movie that I was in called zookeeper
with Kevin James Way back in the day.
And I had to learn how to dance.
And then I had to learn how to dance
with Leslie Bibb from Talladega Nights.
She,
my ex girlfriend and was trying to win
back from Kevin in the movie,
so I had to learn how to,
like there was a scene where we dance in
this ballroom and uh,
you know,
if you realize how difficult it is for
ours,
we're practicing these moves and it's
fucking monotonous.
And here's the thing,
I don't give a fuck about dancing.
So it's something like I had to force
myself to do that I didn't really want
to do.
I'm just not that I don't give a fuck
about other dancing's fun if you just do
whatever you want,
but when you're doing this very specific
pattern to certain music and you did.
Ugh.
Yeah.
Oh yes.
This is the scene,
James.
Gosh,
look at you.
Yeah.
We had to practice this shit over and
over again for weeks and weeks.
What was that?
You.
Yeah,
it was,
it was exhausting.
There was a lot to it.
That was so stupid.
It's so hard.
Dancing is so hard and just like you,
I.
Wow.
That's good.
I don't,
I don't care about it.
I,
I don't.
It's not something when I want to be
good at something,
I will give everything to be good at it.
And here's the other thing,
if you have a natural ability to begin
with,
if someone goes,
you've got to,
you kind of knack for this,
you go,
oh well I'm good.
I'm going to keep trying.
When I walked into this,
I've never.
No one's ever been like,
you've got rhythm girl.
No one's ever.
No one's ever given me even the
slightest nudge towards any kind of,
um,
playing,
you know,
having any musical ability or having any
dance ability if anything.
I've been shamed my whole life.
And then they asked me to do this.
Literally my whole life.
I've never danced at weddings.
I don't dance at concerts because I just
know that I'm going to be made fun of in
some way and obviously no one's even
thinking about me,
but in my head it's,
it's my most insecure thing to do.
I would rather have sex on,
on,
on tv 100 percent.
Then do dancing with the stars.
If there was a sign me up,
Joe.
I'm serious.
This was my biggest fear,
but you can't turn down these things
when they're offered to you.
I feel like,
especially if there's something that
scares you that much as as this did,
I was like,
what do I have diluted?
I'm not going to die doing this.
What's the worst that could happen is
I'm voted off first and they say really
means to the judges say mean things
about my style from.
Yeah,
they got mean to me.
They got really means me fucking super
serious.
Listen,
I got eliminated less than like a week
ago from this show that I gave
everything to and I and I went in saying
I'm a terrible dancer.
I don't know what I'm doing,
and I did a whole dance and I didn't
mess up.
Joe Like I and I got very injured the
day before.
I couldn't even move.
I couldn't get out of bed.
I had to have help because I tore
something in my back and I overcame,
came at mentally.
I talked myself out of having an injury
mentally,
like I meditated my way out of it,
which I've done with several different
injuries in my life of just like I,
I,
I got to be better.
I have to dance on live TV tonight and I
couldn't move.
I couldn't brush my hair because my arm
was hurting so bad that morning,
so I just started saying to myself,
you're strong,
you're prepared and this is easy.
You're strong,
you're prepared.
The ZZ,
and I sent it 3000 times out loud in the
makeup chair all day,
walking around,
slowly going from this kind of injury,
walking like in the morning to,
okay,
I'm strong,
I'm prepared,
this is easy.
And then I.
Then at the end of the day I was,
I danced on live TV and I cured myself
mentally.
It was insane,
but they were so mean to me.
Especially len goodman,
the British,
old Cranky Judge Frisch guy.
The British guys always assholes.
It was,
it was really hurtful and I took it in
stride,
but I was very.
He called me awkward.
Like I,
I just wanted to walk away from this
show,
not being like a white girl dancing
meme,
you know,
like I just didn't want people to be
like,
Oh,
white girls can't dance because I know I
can't dance in and I just didn't want to
be made fun of.
And he made fun of me.
He was like,
you look awkward because at the end of
it I just go,
I can dance.
Like it was just me being funny because
I obviously can't.
But I was like,
I just completed a dance that if you
walk,
it's not that terrible.
I was very injured that morning.
I was proud of myself and he goes,
you will awkward and you can't dance,
you can't dance.
And then he,
he said other things that I just,
I kind of blacked out during it because
it was so sad and I was just holding
onto Tom Bergeron for dear life.
And um,
and then I got eliminated first.
So it's so funny to me because I took on
this challenge being like the worst that
could happen is that I get eliminated
first,
which I surely won't do because that's,
I can't be that bad.
I'll be better than somebody,
somebody 13 of 13 people and I wasn't,
I was the worst.
My worst fear did happen.
I got made fun of on TV.
I got eliminated first and you know,
like being on a reality show,
like have you done a reality show where
it's like and the next to the first,
the first contestant eliminated from the
show and then there's dinner and there's
a spotlight on you and I'm staring at
the stage,
like just a slat in the stage.
I'm just staring there being like
they're going to say Nikki and gloves,
they're going to say Nikki and Globe and
they Nikki and Gla.
And it was just like,
I'm on a reality show right now.
Getting eliminated.
It was so surreal and it sucked.
It sucked.
And I'm still obviously very much
feeling it.
And I loved the show.
I wanted to like,
keep going.
I wanted to do different dances.
I like was ready to really because I
just learned how to learn how to dance,
so I had to learn how to learn how to
because I'd never danced before in my
life,
never learned the mark arena like I was.
I took myself out of any kind of dancing
that was offered to me in school because
I was just like,
I'm a bad dancer.
I don't want.
I wanted to make fun of me.
I'll never dance and I sign up for the
show.
I learn a dance.
I nail it as much as I can nail
something.
I was very proud of myself and then I
get eliminated and it,
it really.
Obviously I'm still,
I'm just.
Has Anybody ever done it?
Two years in a row?
I would love to do it.
I was almost.
No,
but I want you start taking dancing
lessons.
I would love to.
Why don't you do that and then come back
next year and shove it up that British
guys ass.
I don't think they'd want me back.
I bet they would.
I bet they have a hard time getting
people to do that show.
Why did they let me go so soon then joe?
Because it didn't feel like it was
because of my
sing.
It felt,
you know,
when you get eliminated from one of
these shows that you just go,
oh,
they don't.
Someone at the top doesn't like me.
There's something else involved here.
It's not okay.
It's probably just butt out of 13
people.
They liked me the least.
Well,
maybe just being honest,
you had the worst performance.
Isn't that possible?
I mean,
you,
you don't.
Didn't look.
If I was on with you,
I probably would have had the worst
performance.
I don't fucking dance.
Right.
So it's like you think about your base
that you're coming from.
You're not a person who dances.
This is a totally new thing for you,
but if now you have this in your head
and you decide to take dancing lessons
and you do it on a regular basis just
once,
twice a week for a year,
you can be fucking amazing by time next
year rolls around.
I really,
I got to see if they allow people to
enter a second,
continue.
They will will.
Look,
I,
it's fucking hard to get people to do
that show.
A lot of people say no.
A lot of people.
It's a massive commitment.
A lot of people don't have the courage
or the time or the interest in sending
twice and got the same place
looking good.
For me,
that was a different host to the same
house.
It was a different host,
different judges because the first time
I did it I was in college and I liked.
There was no reason for me to even get
as far as I got.
Let's be honest.
It was rigged.
What did you ever host or hostess?
No,
it was one of the judges and there was.
There was a real issue of with one
season,
not with mine,
but with Brett Butler,
drew Carey and a couple other people.
They protested because the person they
voted for did not make it through
because the producers decided that they
knew better and because they wanted the
television show to be more interesting,
so they wanted someone more
controversial or whatever,
whatever it was.
So it was this huge deal where they're
like,
wait a minute,
why are we here as judges if you're not
even counting our vote,
like this is all a puppet show,
like what?
What's happening here?
And then there was also conflict because
one of the guys who was a producer was
also a manager of some of the people
that were on the show and people like,
what the fuck?
You know?
There was a lot of issues.
There was a lot of issues with that
show.
Yeah.
But I think that's every realities,
but it's a context.
There's rules.
Like I would tell people like that want
it to be on fear factor.
Like they would say,
hey man,
can you get me on fear factor?
I'd say it stopped right now there's
very specific rules about game shows.
Like I can't even talk to you if you
want to be on the show.
I can't say,
hey man,
I'm going to get you on the show because
I like you and I'm gonna help you.
I can't do that.
You can't.
Even if you want to be on the show,
don't talk to me because if,
if I have to go to court.
Do you remember that?
That show quiz show?
Yeah,
the,
the movie was based upon that
controversy,
fraudulent show because during that show
they decided this one guy who was
winning,
they decided it was a great thing to
have him keep winning and so they rig
the show and because of that there's
actual federal laws about how you
organize and run game shows.
It's,
there's a real laws behind.
So then that's why I think I can't go
back.
I really,
I love this idea.
I would like to tell ABC I am interested
in coming back and any of this
and I guarantee you you can go back.
I would love to go back.
I had the best time.
I just want to be a dancer now.
Like I stopped doing comedy because I
just wanted to focus solely on dancing
and I started doing comedy towards the
end because you do something for hours a
day that you're terrible at.
You want to go do something you're good
at just to like get your ego back in
place,
because I was beaten down for hours a
day of just,
I'm terrible and I was able to get to a
place where I could kind of have my,
uh,
my teacher gloves of Django is one of
the best dancers in the world.
He would just say like,
I've never been a teacher teaching dance
since he was 14 years old.
And he was like,
I've never met someone who is so bad at,
like I've never met
someone who's.
I go,
I'm special needs dancing.
Like if this were a,
I would be on the short bus for dancers.
I just don't have whatever it takes.
But I worked hard enough that I was able
to learn a very difficult to know.
Stop you there.
It's not that you don't have what it
takes as you've never exercised it.
Yes.
You know how to move.
You're not ambulatory,
you know,
I don't
to say that I'm disabled in any way,
but whatever some people are born with
that gives them a natural rhythm and
like ability to dance.
I don't,
I'm coming out a little of that and a
lot of it is just a bunch of dancing and
they danced at all.
Yeah,
I mean think about it.
I mean if you never played basketball
and you went and played basketball,
you.
God Damn it.
I'm terrible.
I thought it was going to kick ass.
Yeah.
You know,
that's.
A lot of people feel like that about
fighting.
Like a lot of people think if I ever
fought out,
fuck people up like you.
Yeah.
Good luck.
You think that good luck.
That's the thing is I wanted,
I kept saying down the barrel of the
camera,
I'm like,
if you're watching at home being like,
why can't this girl do this?
Because it would be like clapping that I
couldn't get or walking and clapping
together and I could just picture people
at home watching me struggle and be
like,
oh,
I could do that.
Like I say to the computer when I watch
this stuff,
but I'm like,
until you do it,
you don't know how hard this is.
It.
Look,
everyone assumes that they can do it
just like stand up.
But here's the difference with standup
is like I had people just like you did
throughout your childhood and growing up
be like,
you're funny,
you've got like no one's ever been like,
you should dance.
Like No.
What do you mean?
Like we have a natural knack at what we
do that's kept us,
that made us even try it in the first
place.
Right.
Who was the first person that you
remember being like,
you're funny.
Well,
the,
there's like one guy in specific that
I'm still very good friends with.
His name's Steve Graham.
He's an ophthalmologist actually.
And when we were,
uh,
we were friends,
I was 15 and he was probably in his late
twenties and we were training together.
We're doing martial arts together and he
was just,
I would just do impressions of our
friends and,
and he was like,
you should be a comedian.
And I was like,
get the fuck Outta here.
And there's no way,
man.
I was like,
look,
I'm,
I say fucked up things that you think
are funny because you're fucked up too.
Like regular people are gonna think I'm
an asshole.
Like,
I just wanted to make people laugh that
were around me.
I didn't know.
And then I started going,
uh,
I went to an open mic night and then I
realized like,
oh,
there's like a whole,
this is like martial arts.
Like there's a whole process of
learning.
Like I didn't think of it that way.
I thought people were just really good,
you know what I mean?
Like,
Hey,
it's Jerry Seinfeld.
Like when I was in high school,
when I was in high was senior in high
school,
this girl that I was dating,
we went to see Jerry Seinfeld at the
paradise.
It was this big club and in Boston.
And I remember sitting there thinking
like,
this guy's incredible.
He's just talking and all these people
are laughing.
Like this is amazing.
What a,
what a crazy ability to do that,
you know?
And just,
wow,
that blew me away.
And then a couple of years later I was
doing it.
So it's weird.
It is.
But that's,
I would love to see a picture of you in
that crowd that night.
Never having been on stage with a mic.
Like,
and then look at you now.
It's just so crazy.
Those moments of like in your life where
you were at a Jerry Seinfeld show going,
Whoa,
I could never do that.
Joe Rogan.
That's so nuts.
It was weird,
but now you're just like you and Jerry
Seinfeld to me are like one in the car.
Like that's the same,
so that's,
that's cool.
But what I'm saying is that you need
these people in your early on.
You need to be.
I would never have done standup comedy
had someone not been like,
you should be a comedian.
I was desperate for anyone to give me
any kind of direction.
And then some one person says at one
ophthalmologist says it and then it
becomes your career and that's why I'm
always.
I always try to just tell what I'd see
people like something in someone.
I try to say that because you don't know
if you're the one person that's going to
get them to go do it.
I do that too.
I've tried to talk like 100 people into
being comedians.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
What was trying to tell friends that I
have that are funny,
I'm like,
you should just try it.
Just go up at an open mic night and give
it a shot.
I would just say do it if you want to do
it,
do it now because you're going to do it
eventually and you're going to regret
not doing it sooner.
You might not do.
There was a nurse that used to work at
this doctor's office or to go to.
She was fucking hilarious and I was
always telling him,
listen to me.
You should fucking do comedy.
You really should try it.
And she never did it,
you know?
And I went there for years and she
thought about doing it,
so I'm going to call them to open mic
night.
I go,
tell me when you're going.
I'll go.
I'll go,
I'll meet you there.
I'll,
I'll help you.
I'll introduce you to the whole process.
I'll show you how it works.
I'll show you.
There's a signup.
People go up.
Listen,
she's not meant to do it.
Well,
it's like,
what's that expression?
You can lead a horse to water,
but you can't make them drink.
Yeah.
It's like,
I know,
but just I think you have to be fucked
up to want that kind of rejection and
humiliation that we got in the early
days.
The early days too.
Like people see you now.
You go up in the main room.
Hit Ladies and gentlemen.
Nikki glaser.
Yeah.
Clap,
clap,
clap.
Thank you.
Goodnight.
Seems like fun.
Hey,
that seems like a great Gig,
but see you.
When you're an open miker and you're
around all those fucking psychopaths
that are signing up for open mics.
They're all smelly and and sons in
Kansas City.
Oh my God.
I heard Craig just died recently.
Know gone beetlejuice because your dog.
Do you like this?
Hey,
you want to really work here?
Come sit on Craig's lap.
Uncle craigy.
Yeah.
That takes me right back.
Dude.
Started there.
That was a fun Gig.
It was a fun gag.
I used to love that place.
Classic Road Gig.
Just CD.
Didn't know if you were going to get
paid the full amount.
Good shows too.
Rowdy drunk.
Kansas City is a fun place.
It was a fun place.
I was just there couple weeks ago
and I did some crazy outdoor place.
Some outdoor amphitheater was awesome.
No,
that's good.
it was really great.
I didn't even know it was outdoor until
we got there.
It was
one of those gigs.
Are you like I had done?
No,
I didn't read any of the emails about
this.
I didn't pay attention to is me and
Santina.
Santina was outside.
I was like,
get the fuck out of here.
It's not outside.
What's outside?
It was strange.
Yeah.
I started in Kansas City,
but that's just.
I've been relating it recently.
I'm like working on a bit about
encouraging people early on because I do
look at the people that told me you
should be a comedian when I.
right before I tried it because I was
going to be an actress and then I was
like not really good at this and I'm
not.
I don't care enough to get good at it.
Like I see what it takes to be great at
being an actress and I was just like,
I don't want to do that.
But then someone was like,
you're funny,
you should try standup.
And then that was like,
oh,
I'm,
I care enough about this to like go
through the worst of it and get good.
But I,
I,
I've been exploring recently unstaged
like blow jobs.
Um,
I've been talking through and I think
it's the same thing because I'm not
great at them.
I've never been like,
wow,
you're the best at this.
And I've never been a girl who's like,
I love giving blow jobs.
And I've always heard girls,
like there's some girls that say that
like,
I love second deck and I've always been
say that to you or does it say it's a
guys?
They say it,
it just,
it just out there.
And I've always called bullshit on it
because I just think it's like you're
just serving a guy and you.
There's no way that you can enjoy it.
Like it's not that comfortable of a
thing,
but maybe you get some,
uh,
what's the,
the compersion where you enjoy someone
else's.
Yes.
So maybe it's that,
but now I realize that the difference
between me and those girls is that those
girls,
the first time they gave a blow job,
I guarantee or one of the first times
the guy was like,
you're amazing at this,
you're really good at this,
because when a girl is told or anyone
has told early on the first time they do
something that like,
you have a natural talent at this,
you go,
I,
I do.
And then you do it again and again
because you're like,
I'm good at this,
this is my thing.
And then you get good at it and you're
like,
it's my thing.
But no one ever said that to me about
blowjobs early on.
It was always just kind of like a means
to an end.
And I feel like if someone would have
just been like,
lied to me.
So I am.
I asked guys now like,
just lie to every girl.
If you get a blow job and it's like
mediocre,
just be like,
you're the best at this ever.
Like this is the best job I've ever
received because she will be.
So it'll make her feel good.
What's it gonna hurt that she thinks
she's the best at this thing that she's
not that great at,
but she'll do it a lot because she'll be
like,
I'm great at this and this guy thinks
I'm the greatest at it.
So she'll do it a lot and then by doing
a lot she'll get better and then
everyone wins.
Yeah,
maybe.
Or she could just suck a lot of dicks
and people will lie to her and then her
self esteem gets shattered.
If she runs into the one dude and said,
who the fuck told you you're good at
this?
Nobody told me I was great.
No,
no,
you're not good at this at all.
It's all teeth and you're choking.
This is crazy.
Maybe maybe even a girl that is really
good at them can meet a guy that's like
you're tailing because everyone likes
different styles.
So I think that you run that risk
regardless.
Maybe some guys just like really bad
blow jobs.
Right?
Like some guys like blowjobs from
someone who seems like they've never
done it before,
that way they don't feel like they're
the 90th in line.
Oh,
that's a really good point.
Joe.
Like you could be into a blowjob that's
kind of apprehensive and like,
what am I doing that.
How does this feel like a virgin all
type situation?
Just putting on an act.
It's got pigtails on I just schoolgirl
outfit.
What am I doing?
Wait,
what do you teach?
What do you do with this?
Oh my God,
my friend recently,
because we've talked a lot about,
me and my friend have talked a lot about
how we are insecure that we're bad at
blowjobs and we've taken classes at bay
bland or all these things are way.
Way,
way,
way way wait,
wait,
wait.
They tip,
they give out classes to give blowjobs.
Who's teaching the class as girls or
guys?
Uh,
I think it was like a gay guy and a
woman together.
Jay Guy,
gay guy should know how to suck a dick
because he has one.
I've read everything.
I've watched tutorials.
I just,
it's just not getting through to me.
I haven't,
I try and I'm not like bad at that.
Like I,
I don't think I'm,
I'm bad at them,
but I just,
I think I always was apprehensive
because I think the first thing I heard
about blow jobs was that the first
complaint I would hear around me was too
much teeth and I've always had like
really big teeth in some like smile.
I have vague teeth that abnormal,
but I always just like,
I had buck teeth as a kid so I was
always called me like a beaver.
I was like,
my teeth are going to get in the,
in the way of this,
so I immediately.
That was my biggest issue.
And then you learn that like that's easy
to like work around and then so anyway.
But my friend said that she learned this
new trick where she wouldn't,
she's hooking up,
she'll do a role play of like will you
teach me how to do a blow job?
But she's actually wanting them to teach
her and so it's a hot thing where like
she gets to role play.
But she honestly doesn't know and gets
and then the guy tells her exactly what
to do and then if she messes up,
it's like part of the character as
opposed to her being bad at blow jobs.
So that's my next thing.
I'm going to try thing.
So the guys invested in the project.
Yeah.
And if you mess up your own,
you're just part of your character.
You're just being good at the roleplay.
It's because you're innately better.
But then when you break up,
you're like,
listen asshole,
I sucked 100 Dick before you.
I know exactly what I was doing.
I was trying to make you feel better.
You fucking loser.
But either way they were all bigger than
yours.
All of.
Exactly.
Yeah.
It's um,
yeah.
I,
I don't know,
I have a lot of thoughts about sex.
Obviously I'm,
well your act is very much like that.
It is,
but it's,
and I hate being pegged,
no pun intended as like a sex comic,
but like,
cause I just did this ABC show dancing
with the stars and the whole time I'm
trying to be on my very best behavior.
I,
I want
to play the game,
I don't want to be the sex girl.
Get kicked off in the first episode.
I don't want to offend children watching
at home.
That's.
I've never talked about sex.
So people go,
Ooh,
she's,
you do nightclub comedy,
you're there for adults.
I'm just talking about what I want to
talk about.
Obviously what we all know that,
but I think sometimes people are like
year the sex coming because like I just
think that's the most interesting topic
right now.
That's why I'm talking about it becomes
a problem,
right?
You get labeled.
Yeah.
It sucks because I have ambitions beyond
being a comedian who talks about sex,
but already I brought it there with you
because it is my wheelhouse.
I'm most comfortable talking about it.
It's fun to talk about.
I have a lot of opinions about it.
I was trying to behave myself so much on
dancing with the stars because I don't
want to be labeled as that.
But.
And I also was like,
didn't have sex.
I was 21.
I,
yeah,
I was not.
And then I didn't because I was all
through high school,
I was just like scared of guys.
I don't know why I was just scared of
intimacy,
scared of boys,
couldn't,
didn't kiss a boy until I was 17 and
even then it was like one shot deal and
then I didn't do it for years.
And then I got an eating disorder which
like push men away because I looked like
a skeleton and then as soon as I was
able than I,
I had sex.
But it was years and years and until I
started like drinking,
I couldn't have sex.
And then I quit drinking and I couldn't
have sex again.
Thinking about how many
the people have gotten laid because of
booze.
Every one dming Joe,
do you remember when there was this
ridiculous time just a few years ago
where they were trying to push this
narrative that if you have sex with
someone who's been drinking,
that you're a rapist even if you're
drinking to this is this weird third
wave feminist nonsense where they were
like adults going to grown adults have a
couple of drinks.
You're not supposed to do that because
they can't consent because they're
drinking and so people were literally
calling people and accusing people of
rape because they had sex with each
other while they were both drunk.
No.
Well,
this was a.
well,
here's it was a real weird time and
they've abandoned it because it's so
preposterous and the pushback was so
hard,
but you're responsible for yourself
every other time when you're drunk,
if you're driving,
you're responsible.
If you get in a fight,
you're responsible,
you're responsible during all those
things,
but somehow or another if you and a
person or exchanging pleasure,
then you are not responsible for your
actions and you can't consent to that
because you've been drinking and then it
becomes rape and it's only really only
rape.
In the case of the guy,
it's never raped a girl rape the guy
because the guy was drunk.
Right.
Even though I know stories of where
that's happened,
where a guy wakes up from a blackout and
a girl is stuck in this deck.
Yeah.
And that's.
And he's like,
Hey,
do I know if it was the other way
around?
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
But obviously it's not the same.
No.
And no one would be having sex if we
didn't,
if we didn't have alcoholic few people.
So few people because 30 percent of the
people having sex,
think about casual sex.
That's my whole point right now is like
I can't have,
I'm single.
I can't even have casual sex because I'm
sober.
So how long have you been sober?
Seven.
It'll be seven years in December.
From alcohol?
Yeah.
And before then I was hooking up a left
and right.
It was so fun.
I was blacking out just to have sex
because I was scared of intimacy.
I'm realizing all of this now is like,
I know the whole deal.
You're doing all that.
Yeah,
I go through therapy.
I work on myself constantly.
I meditate,
I do all the things and I'm,
I,
I don't know if I'm any.
I am better for it,
but I realized that I'm not getting,
I'm not having sex and it's not fun like
I am.
I'm hooking up with ex boyfriends,
which you know,
that's because there's no pressure there
of like,
this is new and am I going to catch
feelings?
It's like they've already been had or
the or the bubble up again.
You just get to scratch an itch.
Yes,
yes.
But,
but having new sex casually,
like I just can't.
I can't even imagine doing that.
But I had so much when I drank because
it just makes everything easier and I
used to just.
And I asked the crowd sometimes.
I'm like,
have you guys ever.
Who here has had sex for the first time
with someone?
We're.
Both of you were stone cold sober first
time sex.
Literally two people raised their hand
and in the main room and go
of the story.
No,
exactly.
you're so right.
No one listening at home right now.
Wherever you are.
Have you ever had sex for the first time
with someone where you're both sober?
It doesn't happen in our society.
Well,
alcohol gets abused for sure,
but it also gets used,
used correctly.
There's good things to alc.
I think it's a technology that
alleviates a lot of your inhibitions and
it makes people feel better and that's
it for that reason.
You.
Are you an addict?
I mean,
is it possible that you could drink a
little bit?
I'd be fine drinking a little bit.
I know I would first thing you say
before you wake up in the gutter,
exactly
how I am with weed and I have to,
I start out and I go,
I'll just get high as a treat,
you know,
after a set and then I go,
that'd be fun to be high for the set and
then it's like it'd be fun to be high
when I wake up in the morning.
And so it always,
it always snowballs into I'm high all
day and then I have to go.
Okay.
Sober October and I quit for a month and
then build it back up again.
Is that what you're doing right now
with.
We'd,
like you say you're sober,
sober with alcohol,
but
I smoke a little weed and I've gone
years in the seven years of not smoking
weed and um,
but I'm back on it.
I quit for dancing with the stars
because my short term memory
was shit and you can't learn dance steps
when you're high.
I thought I might like help me,
but no,
I think if you already knew it,
if you had it locked in your memory then
it would be good because you'd feel it
more.
Yes,
but it was terrible for me.
So I quit for three weeks and the second
I got eliminated I started again and
have.
So it's been a week of me smoking weed
again and it's already like it's,
you know,
the snowball effect is in,
is in play,
but we does not derail my work ethic.
It makes me work out more.
It makes me think in a different
creative way and it eventually impedes
me when it starts to interfere with my
voice.
If I start getting like horse more
because I'm doing radio every morning
and then I'm going to make you hoarse.
Yeah.
Because I just like,
I don't know how to inhale or something.
I just want you use edibles.
I do,
but those aren't.
I liked like,
I like to feel it in my lungs and feel
it immediately.
If there was an immediate edible I'd do
it.
But um,
I like those too.
But again,
those fuck up my voice too.
I don't know what I'm doing wrong.
Yeah.
But um,
yeah,
I so wish.
But with alcohol I will say like I just
could see it snowballing into a point
where I would quit again,
but I just have never.
I miss drinking a lot for the sex thing,
for the dancing thing.
Like just dancing to music in general.
Like is more fun.
Like if you drunk just life,
like first who drinks,
like life is pretty great for drinks,
good.
Sending text messages.
I don't want to send reaching out to
guys they don't want to talk to in the
morning.
All of that anxiety.
The hangover.
That's what I'm avoiding is the hangover
and with we need.
I don't have a hangover.
You can hang from weed.
No.
No,
but for sure.
And does it make you want to quit and
question everything?
I mean,
how do you keep your drinking in check?
Um,
I've never had a problem with drinking
in like,
it's never been like,
God,
I need a drink.
I've never been like,
like,
like sober.
October was the first time I did
absolutely nothing for a whole month.
I didn't smoke a joint,
I didn't do mushrooms,
I didn't,
nothing,
right?
Wasn't that hard.
What was interesting about it was the
dreams,
first of all,
because the dreams come hard and fast
when you're off the weed and they,
because apparently I talked to this Guy
Dr Matthew Walker,
who is a dream specialist and he was on
the podcast discussing the importance of
sleep sleep specialist,
I should say,
but he was saying that marijuana impede
certain aspects of rem sleep,
which is when you do all your dreaming.
So when you,
um,
get off the marijuana,
your brain apparently makes up for lost
time and hits you with some crazy
fucking dream talking frogs and fucking
Unicorns and roller coasters that go
straight to heaven and fucking bananas
dreams or my gut.
Well,
the thing is this time for a sober
October,
I was way tapered off by the time this
rolled around.
Like I a little pot in Toronto on
Saturday,
but I mean a little like I took like one
or two hits.
I had a drink,
maybe two drinks.
I think I had one drink when I went on
stage and then I had a couple glasses of
wine after the show who went out to this
restaurant after the show.
But yeah,
it was.
This was an easy one because I was kind
of.
But I,
I think I slowed down after last year.
I think doing that a sober October thing
made me realize like,
hmm,
there's some,
there's some of that school that right.
Unfortunately that is all my favorite
comics did drugs.
All of them picks Kennison prior.
Everyone did drugs.
They were,
they were all.
I mean prior was coke.
I've never touched coke but Kennison was
coke too,
but Hicks was more psychedelics and I
mean he did coke and alcohol and all
that other stuff before,
but there was,
there was all.
They were all like these wild fucks.
Like Ron White is a good friend of mine,
always drunk and there's like this part
of that life that,
you know,
there's so it's so attractive because
it's just like this wild,
loose,
carefree,
rebellious,
figured out tomorrow life and that's,
that's the life of the comic.
But I realized like after last year,
so by October that there's a lot of that
stuff you could do if you're sober and,
and it's,
I think as I said,
you can abuse alcohol,
but you can also use it,
you know,
you can use it,
you can,
you can have a couple drinks and feel
good and you enjoy the moment more.
You know,
there's,
there's something,
there's something to it,
but it's really a matter of your own
personality and discipline.
It's like how much and how much of an
addict are you?
Like what,
how much,
what is it,
what holes are missing in your brain
that get filled up with that booze and
that like once you take the booze away,
there's this gaping chasm that you need
to fill in.
What is that?
And you got to figure out who you are.
Because I know some people that can't
have anything,
they have one drink and then they're off
to the races and they're doing math.
Yeah.
No,
that's not me,
but it's,
I just,
I,
I would get blackout drunk a lot and
well after a couple beers,
like were you less secure then the newer
now?
Yeah,
way,
way less secure,
but I think being sober has helped me
become more secure.
But because you're forced to be in the
moment,
I just,
I worry about my depression too,
like with adding booze on to depression,
which I feel like I have a good handle
of right now.
I just don't want to lose it because I
think that like,
I don't know,
obviously alcohol is a depressant and so
I think that and,
and the people that I,
I,
I get really,
really depressed and like in a dangerous
way where I'm like,
I gotta watch it.
Like I got to be vigilant about
meditating every day to keep my
depression at bay because
what do you think that is?
Do you think that's a genetic thing?
Do you think it runs in your family?
I think it must run in my family.
I think we have stuff that I haven't
even like get found out,
but like there's some suspicious deaths
in my family that I'm like,
was that suicide?
You know,
where I'm like,
I think it's described.
Feels like,
what does your depression feeling?
It feels like it.
Honestly.
I get suicidal thoughts.
Not like I just,
I should kill myself.
It's like kill yourself.
It would be fun to kill yourself.
They come from literally soothing.
It soothes me to think about killing
myself when I'm in my worst depressive
stages.
And it is,
I compare it to like sniffles when
you're getting a cold,
like I have a little,
a little thought will go,
oh,
shoot yourself in the head.
Like it literally comes into my head
like a sniffle where you're like,
Oh God,
I'm getting sick again.
Okay,
I got to meditate now and then it'll.
And then I'll be fine.
Like literally it's like that.
And what is,
what's before the shoot yourself.
Nothing.
And that's the,
that's the problem is like,
it just is,
you know,
it can be,
it can be.
Um,
it may be,
it's circumstantial little bit like
maybe I'm feeling lonely that day or I
didn't get a thing that I wanted or I,
but I really do think it's like the
weather,
like I just can't even describe it.
I remember Sarah Solomon talking about
her depression.
Like it's just a cloud comes over you
and you're just like,
oh,
well here it comes.
And that's kind of how it feels.
And I totally have it under control when
I'm meditating everyday doesn't,
I don't get a single one of those
thoughts.
But like if I skip a day,
if I don't do tm one day,
those thoughts keep,
they come in and then if I.
and then you see if you get into a real
bad spot,
you,
those thoughts start.
I,
and I've never even so much as made an
attempt or even planned to make an
attempt.
Like it's never gotten to that even
close to that for me.
But I realized that these are the same
kind of thoughts that people that end up
doing this start with like there's some
kind of like I,
I,
I'm,
I'm a people who love me and care about
me get so upset when I talk about this,
but I think that more people struggle
with these thoughts then talk about.
So I,
I'm eager to share it because I don't
think I'm ever going to kill myself and
I don't think that that's.
But I think that like a lot of people,
I'm at risk and I don't think that
people talk about that enough then
because I do have these thoughts and I
go,
it's not even like I go,
what can I do to make myself feel bad?
Oh,
I could kill myself.
And literally it's like kill yourself.
It's like a little voice or something.
And I've struggled with mental illness
before.
I mean I had anorexia where it was like,
don't eat.
And you're like,
where's that?
Who's that?
But it's,
it's a voice.
Did you have,
don't eat because you thought you were
overweight or don't eat because you
thought you'd be more attractive.
If he looks like
all,
I'm a rail,
I mean this vague direction vague or was
it just like an obsession?
It was,
it started out like,
you know,
um,
high school,
I should be skinny.
Everyone should be skinny.
I admire,
I like wanted to be famous someday and I
looked at,
I admire like I idolize everyone in the
magazines,
the whole classic thing of like looking
literally in magazines and I want to
look like that.
I hate myself pinching my sides being
like,
if I'm not like that then I'm worthless.
Having a mom who constantly hated her
body was skinnier than me and constantly
said she was fat and things like that
where you just,
you have things modeled for you.
So I grew up thinking skinny equals more
lovable and then I lost weight just
because,
um,
my senior year I lost weight because of
boy liked me that I liked who I liked
back and I was like very nervous about
it.
Like,
you know,
when you just get nervous so you can't,
you don't eat that day.
And I had a date with this guy was my
first date ever.
And I just,
that day I didn't eat because I was just
nervous and then the next day it showed
up on me because someone goes,
you look great,
what's going on?
And I was like,
oh,
I just didn't eat yesterday.
Like I can do that again.
So it's basically the same thing as
saying,
you're really funny.
You're open to suggestion.
I'm really good dude.
I know I,
I'm scared of it.
The thing is I,
I am open to suggestion,
but the thing is I am good at,
at losing weight.
I can,
I can stick to a diet and I can black
and white things.
I can say I'm not drinking for seven.
I can,
I can quit things,
I can quit eating and I have good.
It's like willpower.
And I learned that like Oh for the first
time,
like I could do this.
And so I just stopped eating.
And then the for a while you get like
super hot.
Like I was very popular for a couple of
weeks.
And then for a hot second,
I was hot for a second and then I got so
scary skinny and then I couldn't stop
your.
You were just like,
I go,
well I don't.
Everyone's like,
hey you looked great like a week ago.
Like right now it's kind of of concern.
And I'm like,
well I don't know what to do because if
I eat I'll just get fat again.
And so I just,
this is all I know now.
And then it becomes if you eat your week
and then it becomes obsessive compulsive
and then it's not even about being fun
anymore because you look in the mirror
and I would look in the mirror and go
like,
you're disgusting.
Like I looked like I w I look like
Holocaust pictures.
Like that's how bad I looked at photos
from back then to make sure that you
don't ever get back to that spot again.
I won't ever get back to that spot again
because I'm too vain to do that now.
And I know like what I see it coming.
It's the same way of like pot when I see
it starting to interfere with my life,
I go,
okay,
you need to stop drinking and smoking
pot.
And when I see myself get too skinny now
I'm like,
okay,
you need to stop working in chaos,
but you kind of have a handle on it.
Oh,
I totally have a handle on it.
I won't ever be anorexic or die of
depression.
Like all these things I won't,
like,
I'll go a different way.
But like those things aren't going to
get me because they almost got me
before.
I mean anorexia.
I should have died.
I was going to die from it.
And I planned on dying from it and
planned on time from.
Because Joe,
I was starving.
It sucks to be starving and on doing
this because I wanted to die.
I was like,
some,
it was a slow suicide.
I was like,
I stopped weighing myself because it was
so dangerous to get attached to a
number.
But the last time I remember wearing
myself I was 98 pounds.
That was when I was admitted to a psych
ward when I was 18 and
I'm five nine.
And what do you weigh now?
I'm 1:35
now and I'm skinny now.
So yeah,
you're not,
you're not stretching imagination like
35 pounds lighter than this plus more
crazy.
I was so thin.
I was so like,
that's crazy.
Everywhere I went people would point and
whisper and talk.
It was one of those things where it was
like,
you know,
you've seen girls out and about like
that.
Do those to go to my yoga class.
That was terrifying.
She was so scary.
She looked like.
I mean she was a small person too.
She was only like five,
one or five to and she looked like she
probably weighed 80 pounds.
It was awful.
It's,
that's the way people.
And I see girls like that now and I,
I do the same thing that people used to
say to me,
which is like just eat a sandwich bitch.
Like what are you doing with Kim?
I know you can't say that,
but I don't even relate to the person I
was when I wasn't eating because the
only way you can say is like,
I could not eat,
I could not do.
It was almost like if you were to like,
if a protein shake,
it was like drinking poison.
Like I'm gonna die if I drink this.
It was that hard to,
to eat.
I don't get.
I,
first of all,
I was admitted to a hospital because I
was going away to school.
Um,
I lost all this weight and like a couple
months,
like it went away quickly for me and it
got scary fast.
The school called my parents.
My parents were in denial because they
didn't want to believe that their
daughter was like dying.
So they were kind.
They were concerned.
But like I was lying to them about,
oh,
I'm going out to eat.
I'm not going to be here for dinner
night.
Just lying,
lying,
lying.
I went to the doctor to get a physical
because I was going away to school in
the fall.
This was July.
I went to go get a physical and my
pulse.
I have like a low pulse anyway,
like I Brady Cardia.
It's I think it's 37 to 42 resting.
You have an issue.
What is it called?
It's called Brady Cardia.
It's just like a low resting pulse rate.
I don't know.
An exercise?
No.
I exercise a lot,
but even when I don't exercise a lot,
I still just have a low.
Do you do a lot of cardio?
I do a lot of cardio now.
Yeah,
but I really liked this elite athlete.
Resting heart rate's like Lance
Armstrong.
I'm really proud of it,
but I do nothing to support it.
Like I run every day but not like enough
to boast that,
but it saved my life because I didn't
know I had a low pulse rate,
but when I went in for this thing that
this physical,
the doctor clearly could see I was
anorexic because they looked at me and
weighed me,
but they didn't have any kind of data to
keep me,
but until they took my pulse and they
were like,
if you leave you're going to die and
you're going to be a liability to us
because we know so you can't leave.
You're going to owe you a 50 1:50
or whatever it is where you're committed
to a second one.
So I went in for a checkup,
was taken on a golf cart,
the golf cart to the other side of the
hospital where I was checked into a
psych ward.
And my mom's like,
no,
she's not in there.
Like,
yes she is.
And so I was admitted there and I had to
stay there for a couple of weeks I
think.
And then I lied to get out of it because
I ate just enough to get out.
And then I went to school,
I convinced my parents I was okay to go
away to school,
which I wasn't nearly died.
They're just starving myself and
exercising too much and that.
But that,
that is how I got out of it was that so
I wanted to die because I was hungry all
the time.
Being hungry socks and I couldn't eat.
I didn't know how to eat.
I didn't know even know how to begin to
eat.
So I was like,
every night I would just pray that I
wouldn't wake up because I would go to
bed freezing cold because you have no
fat so you're cold.
You have to wake up.
I was going to school in Colorado.
I was ill prepared for the weather and
also I had no fat on my buddy was.
It was an awful existence.
And then I did stand up comedy for the
first time because yeah,
because when I went to school my
freshman year,
I was so crazy looking like I was.
I was like,
I was like the nightmare before
Christmas.
Jack skeletal.
Yet that is what it looks like.
I was.
I look at pictures,
I'm like,
how did you have friends,
bitch,
but I did because I became really funny
because I wanted people to go look over
here,
don't look at me,
so I just,
I was a shy kid in high school when I
was not anorexic,
but then when I needed to make friends
because I was one school loan,
I was like,
oh,
I'll just develop this really over the
top personality so people don't notice
that I'm so thin.
So that's when I became funny.
Really funny,
you know,
I was always like,
dormantly funny,
but that's when it became like outwardly
funny.
People started telling me how it should
be a comedian.
My freshman year I tried it,
I did it one time and then I was like,
oh,
I have a reason to live now.
Like I have a purpose and I know that
sounds so stupid,
like cliche to say like,
oh,
gave me comedy.
Gave me a reason to live,
but it really did because I didn't know
what that.
I was like,
what am I going to become a teacher?
I don't care.
I'm not passionate about that,
but this,
I was like,
okay.
So then I was like,
I got,
I have to gain some weight if I'm going
to now have a career.
So then I started,
I found a therapist.
I was like,
I got to beat this.
I started reading books.
I found a therapist and I found this one
therapist who told me the thing that
really broke through,
which was like,
when you have anorexia,
everyone's just eat something.
Why aren't you eat something?
And you feel very in control of it and
you feel like you're the one to blame
for it because you're the one that's
choosing not to eat and you're the one
that's choosing to exercise.
And,
and um,
and so I felt all this shame about like,
why can't I cured myself?
Why am I giving myself this thing that's
ruining my life?
And then this therapist was like,
think of it as like cancer.
Like you got,
you got sick,
like something invaded your life and
there is a demon inside you telling you
don't eat and it's not you.
It's not you.
So don't listen to that voice.
And then as soon as I was able to like,
disassociate my illness from like,
it's my choice,
it's my doing,
I'm not eating.
And I was able to see it as like the
exorcist,
like that little girl has like a demon
inside insider.
That's like dominique pitch,
eat if you eat your week.
As soon as I was able to go shut up
voice,
then I was able to eat again.
It was like one nugget of one way of
perceiving my illness that was able for
me to like crack it.
And then it took many years to like.
And I still struggle with controlling
issues over food,
but I'll never be anorexic again.
But yeah,
it was that,
it was um,
it was a mixture of comedy and also
therapy that
with alcoholics too,
that that's one of the reasons why
alcoholics,
when they talk about,
they talk about it,
like it's a disease and people who
aren't alcoholics who are judgmental
global.
It's not a fucking disease.
Cancer's a disease.
Leukemia disease,
you'd as weak.
But if they treat it like it's a
disease,
then you can cure it.
But if you,
if you treat it like your week,
then you just shit on yourself.
Like,
oh,
I'm weak.
I just want another drink.
Like what is it about me?
Why do I need this booze?
And there's this weird cycle,
this loop,
this that goes on in your brain,
you know,
like,
I don't want to drink.
I don't want to drag.
Dammit.
I drank.
I'm never gonna drink again.
Fuck,
I'm drinking again.
And then these people that just get
completely out of control.
One of the ways that helps them is to
treat it like it's disease.
Yeah.
I think it's,
I think it was just a real,
a way that I'd never seen.
I had seen so many doctors,
but until that one guy told me to think
of it in like literally did the thing
where he put a chair in the corner of
the room and was like,
talk to your disease,
tell it what it's done to your life.
And I had to.
And I go,
this is too.
I'm not doing this.
Fuck.
It took me 30 seconds until I was
sobbing,
screaming at this empty chair.
But it,
I mean it works.
Have you ever talked about this on
stage?
No,
it's so weird because I'm still,
I feel like I'm still too in it or I
don't know.
I don't know.
I want to be able to someday and when I
am able to,
it'll be like a real huge moment in my
career in life.
But even me being able to talk about it
on podcasts like this or in platforms
like this is new to me still and I've
done it before,
but it's,
it's,
I just feel like I still suffer with so
many of these things that I'm like,
oh,
it's so weird to talk about it.
Like I,
I like to have a little bit more
distance from the.
Even though it's been.
I'm 34 now and I get had anorexia when I
was 18.
I'm still like,
it's still too new,
but sometimes things
16 years seemed like a long time,
you know?
But it goes by quick happens very quick.
It's,
yeah.
I just like to have.
I don't know.
I know what it is.
I'm just still.
I think I'm still so angry about it.
And still,
there's still pieces of it that I'm
like,
how did I get this and how did I have to
save myself instead of someone else
coming in and saving me?
And why didn't someone intervene before?
Can't though,
can they?
I mean now it's kind of,
it's very hard for someone to convince
someone you need to stop drinking or you
need to get your shit together,
you need to do this,
we need to do that.
You need to hit your own bottom.
I know.
And,
but you know,
I feel like yeah,
you just,
I,
there's still things about it that are
really painful to me.
And I think that it,
when I am dealing with something like
that on stage,
I think the pain still shows and I can't
be funny with it yet because I'm still
so angry.
I think I'm still just like angry about
it because I also feel like I'm still a
victim to um,
body dysmorphia,
like crazy.
Like that's my new thing where like,
I'll just see something in the mirror.
Then I'm like,
well,
yesterday you felt the opposite.
I'll go from a 24 hour timeframe from
being like,
you're fat,
I'll look in the mirror and be like,
and then the next day I'll be like,
you're too thin.
And I'm like,
well,
those things can't be possible within 24
hours of themselves.
So your crazy.
Right,
so that.
I mean,
I'm still dealing with stuff like that
and I want to be on the other side of it
and be able to tell girls like,
you're beautiful and your body doesn't
matter and it's what's up here.
That counts.
But I don't.
I'm not there yet.
So I don't know how to,
to,
to really talk about it.
Well,
I don't think.
I don't think there's one way,
you know,
I think everybody's got their own weird
thing that's causing them to have
issues,
whether it's a B to b,
an alcoholic,
or to be addicted to whatever.
You're addicted to everybody.
There's no one you have to figure out
the person and then figure out how this
disease or whatever it is a sort of
interface with that person.
And what is it that happened to you that
made this,
this thing attractive where it fits into
your slots and,
and,
and distracts you from all the things
that are freaking me the fuck out about
your existence.
I mean,
it is a coping mechanism.
If it was so simple that like,
oh well then people are anorexic,
you tell them this and then they go,
oh,
okay.
I mean the.
If there was like a protocol that you
could just establish right away,
oh you just got to take these steps and
then you'll be fixed.
It doesn't work.
And they might work for some people.
You know,
what would really doesn't help,
you know,
it doesn't help that it's so prevalent.
Like there's so many people that have
issues like that.
And the other way too,
like there's people that are
bodybuilders that are crazy,
that can't they,
they the same gang big enough.
It's the same thing.
It has the same goals with giant fake
boobs that they think they need triple f
boobs.
I like the way people see themselves
versus the way other people see them as
very strange.
Yeah,
I know what I've been watching the show
botched.
Have you watched that show?
Yeah,
I've watched that show.
Holy Shit.
I mean that's the same.
They don't,
they don't,
they don't know what they don't see what
we're seeing at.
Oh,
it's,
it's crazy.
This is poor lady who was on the other
day who is getting,
she's getting her nose fixed because she
had so many surgeries that are,
knows collapsed and it was just like,
oh Christ,
you know?
And they had to take a chunk out of her
rib and they rebuilt her nose up.
It came out great at the end obviously.
Which is why they put it on television.
She fixed her.
Oh yeah.
Unless you don't fix inside.
I don't know that bitch done done.
Unless you're fixing what's up here
that's making you look at yourself in
the mirror and go,
I'm uglier.
And that's what I'm in a mad dash to do.
Joe is like,
fix yourself.
Well,
just know to yet to get to love myself
enough through therapy meditation,
just to love myself on the inside enough
that I don't.
Because as I age,
as you age,
especially in this business,
things aren't as good for what as you
age,
as a woman,
things get shittier,
like you become less valuable to society
based on the fact that you're aging.
It's just funny in this business and in
life.
Like I remember the first time I
remember one time I was hanging out in
high school with my girlfriends and I
remember her.
This girl's mom always used to just kind
of say things that she envied our youth
a lot and when you're young you're just
like,
okay,
Old Lady,
what are you gonna?
Get out of here.
What do you do?
You're saying these sad things and then
just walking out of the room silently,
like.
But she would say these things in one
day.
The one thing she said really got to me,
she was like,
you girls are also young and thin and
beautiful.
You know?
I remember,
I remember the last time a man held the
door for me and then she just left the
room and I'm like,
oh,
there's a day that that just stops.
Wow,
that's ridiculous.
I hold them.
Of course for old ladies all time,
that's stupid,
but I,
I think she meant that was the last time
a man who wanted to fuck her and you
know,
when that's in the air when there's a
door being held for you by a guy who was
like,
bug you,
but why is that gender specific?
I mean that's,
that's with men with women.
Men Too.
I,
my dad recently said to me,
he was like,
[inaudible] don't even look at me
anymore.
My Dad's like an attractive guy and he's
like,
I'm like invisible to women and I can
see like a sadness in it and,
and I don't want to.
I know that that's all that will happen
eventually because that is just the way
things go once in a while.
A guy might be,
I'm an older ladies and I'd like to bang
her and I will love that guy so much and
I know those guys are out there and I
hear hear from those guys a lot when I
talk about this stuff,
but those guys are sick.
Just like you were when you were 18
pounds.
I hope they never fixed that thickness.
Please share it with the old ladies are
so needy though.
Thank you.
So you.
So
thank you for that is don't fix that.
We need those guys.
But I just know that that's,
that's on the horizon,
that attention from men and women and
just society will start to wane and
you'll become more invisible physically
to other people and I just hope at that
point I don't give a fuck.
And then I liked myself enough and so
that's what I'm.
I'm like running at that.
Trying to like,
like myself enough on the inside,
which I really have gotten so far ahead
of what I thought I could ever do in
terms of loving myself and working on
myself and getting sober and all the
things.
But I still feel like it's not enough.
Like I'm still,
I still deal with insecurities and I'm
like,
God dammit,
I'm aging and this.
I'm supposed to not feel this.
I'm supposed to not care that I'm aging
as much.
I don't want to be one of these women
that's like a hates aging.
I just don't want to be it.
And I'm kind of,
well you have to be very careful in you
feel about aging,
aging.
I don't think about it
really don't tell you don't because you
seem ageless.
Like honestly,
someone just said your age,
and I was like,
I don't even think of Joe is having an
age.
I honestly don't like.
You seem like an ageless person to me.
And that's because you don't give a
shit.
You don't think of it you this.
I mean this is gonna sound ridiculous,
but you have to eat.
You have to realize that the entire,
your life from birth to death is a blink
of an eye.
It is a very short period of time in
terms of the entire life of the planet,
the life of the human race,
the life of the universe.
It is a blink of an eye.
And for you to be with wear blinders and
concentrate on one tiny little window of
sexual viability,
it's preposterous.
It's ridiculous because the whole,
your whole existence is insane.
It's so bizarre looking at people's
bizarre like how the fuck do your eyes
work?
You're looking through your eyes and
light is refracted through your lenses
and your cornea and you're seeing things
and I know that if I reach,
I can grab.
This can is right there.
I mean all of that is bizarre and so to
to concentrate on this one thing,
when will people stop wanting to stick
their Dick in the me?
That's crazy that I even like,
but it's a crazy.
It's a perspective issue,
right?
Yeah,
and I think the,
the,
the wider you get away from that and one
of the best ways to do that,
a psychedelic drugs,
psychedelic drugs are one of the very
best ways to broaden your perspective
because the experience is so tight,
tonically,
alien and so giant and connects you to
the entire universe itself that when you
come back down to earth,
it seems so preposterous and then you
see this dance that everybody's involved
in,
you know,
with putting on fake butts and fucking
get your lips done and all the chaos
that people are doing just to try to
attract more sexual attention and
knowing that this is so,
so such a short period of time.
One of the things that freaked me out is
what I call monster face.
It's when women get their face pulled
back so far that their mouth looks like
it's bigger because there had been doing
this and so it looks like they could
just open their mouth up like venom and
fucking get your whole head in there and
chop your fucking head off.
It's.
It's a.
it's a sickness.
It's so funny because yeah,
when you get that stuff done,
you end up looking like other people who
have had it done so you get a certain
type of face.
We all know the face.
You're describing like a deep sea
monster,
a deep sea fish.
Yeah.
And shoot things into their cheeks and
make your cheeks puff up because it
eliminates some of the wrinkles.
But then it looks like you've been
beaten up literally like you got fucking
stung with a swarm of bees.
It's better.
Well,
it doesn't.
You know also doesn't work because
there's a thing called the fibonacci
sequence and when you look at a person's
face,
there's a golden ratio of the nose to
the eyes,
the chin,
and as soon as you fuck with anything,
soon as you switch one of those up like
lips,
you're like,
hey.
Like if you look at say like Serena
Williams,
her lips match her face and there's
like,
there's a natural order to that.
If you look at Arusha fear,
his nose matches his chin matches his
face.
There's a,
there's a ratio that it fits in and when
you get a nose job and you're supposed
to have a big nose,
people look at you like,
what the fuck is going on?
What if you have like a Persian face,
like a,
you know,
a big,
robust Persian face.
But you have this little fucking Pixie
Irish knows people like what the fuck is
going on with her face?
This is crazy.
But Joe,
there's so many people that have worked
on that you'd like,
we all know bad plastic surgery,
but there's some that so good and we
think of these people as being born that
way mean there's dinner.
Yes.
That's a perfect one.
I mean,
girls always bring her up,
let it out later that she was a monster.
She's a monster now.
She's gorgeous.
I mean there's some stuff that works,
but you're so right.
Like I want to talk to you about
psychedelics because when did you first
do them?
Most 30 when you were 30.
I think I was a little younger.
No?
Yeah,
yeah.
When I was 13 I started smoking pot and
then a psychedelics dogs came after
that.
And did you.
I mean obviously that,
that was before the time when people
thought psychedelics were a way to like
heal yourself.
Like I feel like this is kind of like a
new movement,
that psychedelics are the answer.
You're around the right people.
Back then you would get that
information.
Were you around the right people?
Is that how you got introduced to them?
Yeah.
I was around a lot of it because of the
fact that I was a comedian.
And then also because of the fact that,
um,
you know,
I was relatively famous back then,
not,
not famous famous,
but like pee.
I was,
I was on television.
I've done some things so people would
want to like turn you onto things,
you know,
like,
and I would go to parties or meet people
and they would,
you know,
say,
hey man,
have you ever done mushrooms?
Know.
And,
uh,
hey man,
you ever heard of DMT?
And the like.
And then there's a few different things
that would happen and you'd be around
these people who had gone to jail for it
or you know,
that we're like real psychedelic heads.
And once I was around a few of those,
I realized like,
well,
there's a whole nother world out there.
And then I discovered Timothy leary and
John Lilly and this flotation tank
became a giant part of my life.
And then,
um,
you know,
Terence Mckenna and Dennis Mckenna and
all the various psychedelic wizards that
are out there that I've been sort of
expressing that there's,
there's a whole world out there that
you're not seeing.
It's like we're living life inside this
very strange tent is a very thin
membrane tent.
And if you just unzip that tent and step
out,
the entire wilderness of the universe
exists.
But most people live their life inside
this very thin walled tent.
And they think that that tent sort of
defines the actual universe itself when
it's,
it's so small and so limited.
Is there a chance that you opened that
tent and you don't like what you see and
now you've fucked your whole life up
because I think that's most people's
apprehension about shure specifically
come back.
Yes,
we'll sit bear it.
You know,
there's been a lot of people that were
um,
I mean,
uh,
I have friends that know friends that
will.
The issue is with psychosis and people
that have schizophrenia,
people that have legitimate mental
illness,
mental health issues.
And they did the argument is correlation
or causation.
Right?
And the argument is,
does the psychedelic drugs caused mental
illness or do a certain amount of people
already have mental illness?
And I think it's much more likely that
the percentage of people that are
schizophrenia remained static.
Because if you,
if you look at it like this,
the number of people who smoke
marijuana,
who are also schizophrenia mirrors the
number of people or schizophrenia
period.
So it's not that marijuana causes
schizophrenia,
so it's a one out of 100 or whatever the
number is.
They just have this issue,
this,
this.
And for those people it's critical that
they avoid psychedelic drugs,
that they avoid marijuana and probably
even alcohol or many even maybe bunch of
other psychotropic drugs as well because
it could.
You've got an imbalance.
Just like someone who has a liver
disease has an imbalance,
just like someone who has a lung
disorder can breathe well,
someone assisting fibrosis or someone
who has any number of diseases.
You've got to kind of think of it that
way.
There's an ailment of the mind.
And so if you add this unknown element
to that ailment,
like five grams of dried mushrooms,
like,
whoa,
who the fuck knows what could happen?
You might never come back.
And then there's the question.
The other part of your question is,
is it possible you could open that tent
and not like what you see and fuck up
your life?
Yes,
yes.
Even if you don't have or a mental
disorder,
you might have a view of the world
that's untenable with the experience
that you have under the influence of
psychedelics,
but that might be the.
Your view of the world is bullshit and
you've been living your life with this
fucking Norman Rockwell nonsense
floating around your head because you've
been so influenced by media,
by songs and by television shows and
buy,
you know,
I want to live like the kids on friends,
they don't even live like that.
Look at them.
They're all fucked up.
Now,
you know,
for the most part,
Jennifer Aniston seems to be not aging.
That's pitches is insane.
That's my girl.
I want to be around her.
I want to find out what she's doing.
What kind of cream are you using?
Cream.
It's lasers.
Whatever the fuck she's doing.
It's amazing.
One hundred and 50 years old.
She looks like she's 12.
It's incredible.
You would feel bad if you had sex with
it.
Like you're having sex with an 18 year
old.
She looks amazing.
She literally hasn't really done Matthew
Perry.
Looks like he's been to hell and back
like that motherfucker went head first
into a sand storm and he got his face
ripped off.
Like he's been just doing math every day
and smoking cigarettes.
One lighting the other from the time
he's awake until the time he goes to
sleep.
He looks like total dog shit and she
looks fucking amazing.
I know they were.
They worked together.
They were both young together.
Shared some skin care.
A fuck.
How the fuck.
I mean that is like a perfect example.
It is a perfect example.
Even she can't keep it together.
Right?
She's on like some new marriage and I
got divorced and it's like there's this
chaos to this business and this what you
were talking about,
like the,
like I've talked about this many times
in the podcast at this business is nuts
because it takes people that are
insecure already and then puts them in a
position where they have to get chosen
for things.
So you have to audition and people have
to decide whether they like you next.
Nikki.
Hm.
Okay.
Nikki.
So a central show.
He had a comedy central show that uh,
didn't work out.
It just,
you know,
there was an internal thing.
It wasn't any good.
You were on dancing with the stars for a
hot minute.
Yeah.
Again,
that was just like,
there were just,
I'm.
That guy was really mean to you.
What was that all about?
I think I've reminded him of a
granddaughter who has called him in the
judges that are such assholes.
Anyway,
so you're reading for Amy and amy is an
anorexic standup comedian who likes to
drink and blackout.
So,
uh,
right up your alley.
So here we go.
And so,
and then you do it and go,
okay,
well thanks a lot Niki.
Good job.
Uh,
okay.
And so you'll call me.
Yeah,
no,
you'll
kind of just watched the show that
you're auditioning for and see someone
else in the role and that's how you'll
know,
scream.
So you.
And
then you walk out feeling like a hundred
percent dog shit.
Like you're from the top of your head to
the bottom of your toes is just dog
shit.
And we do this stuff and you got people
commenting on it and tweeting at you and
saying mean.
It's like you're right.
It's like I'm in this business because
I'm insecure and I want people to
strangers to love me.
And then I don't even accept the love
that they give.
I don't care about the tweets that are
nice.
I reject those and I think you're crazy.
And then I think,
which I don't read comments or anything
like I've been really good about like
self care of that's not ever going to
bring me joy is going through the
comments of a youtube video.
But um,
but still mean things get through and
yeah,
you're right,
like I am a really strong person to be
where I am in this business and have
gotten as far as I've got,
but it breaks me at times still and I'm
scared and I'm spent.
I'm so excited to do psychedelics.
Are you kidding me?
I,
I'm,
I'm excited.
Like I.
Well I want to do it with a shaman if
you're available,
but I wanted to,
I want to do it in like a really
controlled way because I do think it's
the next frontier for me in terms of,
because I'm done with therapy talk
therapy.
I'm like,
this is too slow of a process.
I did mushrooms once but it was not a
good experience because it wasn't bad
setting a very small amount and not
enough to really have a good trip.
Even though it was a small amount of
still a bad experience.
It was just bad because I was hanging
out with two people that are coupled.
That got into a fight while I was with
them and they kicked me out onto the
street in New York City.
While they were on mushrooms,
they don't want to fight on mushrooms.
Yeah,
just got kind of tense hanging out with
them.
We were supposed to just like us three
chill on their roof and like look at the
skyline and just have a nice night.
But then his girlfriend got sick.
They were in a weird kind of bickering
thing.
I was like,
I'm going to go.
I left.
I had been arrested the night before for
smoking weed on the street,
so I'd spent six hours in a holding cell
the night before.
But I had planned to do mushrooms the
day after and the guy was like,
you should still do and we'll celebrate
you getting out of jail.
And I was like,
okay.
So I did mushrooms.
I was broke.
I had just been arrested.
I,
um,
and I was on the street and I remember I
called my parents because I was,
I just felt like the way that smoking
weed is portrayed in movies where it's
like,
oh,
things coming at you.
Like,
you know,
that's the way I felt on mushrooms.
Like,
I don't know if that's the normal way,
but like I felt like everyone was just
like in my face.
I called my mom and I go,
mom,
I'm on mushrooms right now.
I'm on the upper east side.
I'm just trying to get to my friend
Mike's House.
And she goes,
who do you think you're talking to?
You don't call your mom and say you're
on much.
Like she was like for once in our life
she had boundaries.
If she goes,
she goes,
talk to your father.
And so then I talked to my dad.
I was like,
Oh,
I'm on most rooms that I don't know.
And he kind of talked me down,
but I just went home and chugged a
bottle of wine because I was like,
I want to be.
I want to feel something else other than
this because I felt too much.
I felt a lot of love in that scared me.
But this was before I quit drinking a
lot of love.
And that scared you?
Yeah,
I was like calling my friends being
like,
I love you,
like it in a way that I'd never felt
before,
and I was like,
I don't like this feeling,
chug,
chug.
I don't know what.
Maybe it's because you were alone.
I think it was.
I was going through a lot of things that
was like I was,
I think it was billy mic at that time.
This was not a good time in my life.
I had to be doing psychedelics,
but now I think I,
I've read enough about them and I'm
like,
you know,
there are soldiers who have ptsd that go
through talk therapy for years and have
no have minimal amounts of progress and,
and,
and then they do one thing of dmt and
they're like,
I'm good.
Like there's something there.
I can't wait for whatever that is.
I want to do IOWASCA.
I want to do DMT,
I want to,
I want to open up those doors.
Great for soldiers to.
That's their maps is doing some really
serious trials right now with MDM may
assisted therapy.
So they're taking people with PTSD,
whether it's soldiers,
victims of violence,
and they're taking them through a MTMA
assisted therapy and they're having some
pretty dramatic results.
I think it is like the next big.
I'm so excited about it for certain
people and myself.
Like I just
done Mtma ecstasy.
No,
I only did it once and the,
the rebound the next day was horrific
for me.
That was one of the worst hangovers I've
ever had.
Like it wasn't just a hangover,
it was,
I was,
I felt really stupid.
Like I couldn't read.
Like I was trying to read a magazine the
next day I couldn't read and then I had
to perform that night and I kind of ate
shit on stage and um,
but I'll never forget the lessons from
the experience.
It was very powerful,
like a really illuminated how much
insecurity hinders you and inhibits your
ability to communicate with people and
flavors,
how you interact with people.
And how much of my own aggression and
the way I would interact with people was
basically just me being scared.
Like what?
What?
I want to know what Joe Rogan was before
psychedelics,
like what are the things that you
socially,
the hurdles that you've overcome?
Well,
what were you like?
What were the things that you're like,
oh my God,
I can't believe I was like that.
I'm dying to know this.
Well,
you know,
when I was young I was super insecure.
My parents split up when I was really
young and then we moved around a lot so
it didn't have like a base of friends.
And then I found martial arts when I was
a young teenager and what martial arts
did was it gave me something that I
finally felt like I wasn't a loser at.
It was like the first thing that I ever
did where I was like,
oh,
I,
I'm good at something.
I can be really good at something.
And I got good at it really quickly
because I was obsessed.
I was completely addicted and I was
training every day and it became my
identity.
So my identity was that I was really
good at martial arts and so to be really
good at martial arts,
especially in competition,
you have to be,
you have to be very aggressive,
you have to be ruthless and you have to
be like,
you have to embrace this sort of the,
there's,
there's an undeniable violence and
kicking someone in the head,
I mean it's very,
it's very violent,
like martial arts competitions,
extremely violent and you have to be
able to embrace that and the embracing
of that and the terror and the fear of
it all,
just that it shaped my,
my developmental period.
So like when I was 15,
that was my whole life.
That was all I did until I started doing
standup comedy.
So my entire form formative period was
based on violence.
It was all,
it was all.
I mean it was,
it was martial arts.
It was very controlled and well I wasn't
like a bad person who is a beating
people up or anything like that.
But my,
I was ready to go all the time.
Like it was all,
it was always any edit around any
corner.
That might be something the next person
might say the wrong thing and you might
realize you're going to have to fight
them or whatever,
whatever it was,
and that took a long time to let go.
That took a long time to like shake off.
Are you easily angered?
Would you get into fights?
No,
I didn't really get into.
I was smart.
Like I will avoid fights.
So you were 10,
you were anxious?
Constantly.
Well,
I,
my,
my personality developed through
violence.
Me really develop through martial arts,
competition through from the time I was
15 to Thomas Twenty one I traveled the
entire country.
It was all I did was fighting
tournament's.
I fought all the time.
I fought like,
I don't know how many times.
Do you have girlfriends?
Like I mean you were upset you were you
really going to Olympic athlete?
You were an elite elite athlete at 15.
Did you?
What was your 15?
But by the time I was 17 I was boy when
I was 18 I won the state championship.
Well,
to get to that point is my social life
and elite was going to say it had to
have just been know it was,
it was awkward and weird.
You know,
you like with girls and stuff early on
were you.
Did you do okay.
All right.
I mean,
you know,
high school,
I had girlfriends in high school and
then there was a dry period after high
school for sure,
and then once I started doing standup
comedy then then it was easy and there's
a wet period.
Then it was crazy that it's like,
whoa.
It's like,
that is nuts.
But yeah,
my,
my life was all about competing and
being at a gym so there wasn't like a
lot of time to meet people.
It was all very strange.
But there's this getting over that,
that hurt the hurdle of that bizarre
childhood.
Was there a moment
though when you came out of a trip or
what?
Was there a,
like a nugget that you took where you
were like,
oh,
this is bullshit.
Was there a certain trip that you like
look to and you're like,
I emerged a different person and what
does that,
one of them,
one of them highlighted unnecessary
tension.
Highlighted.
What was the last one?
What did you learn in the last trip you
had?
The last one I had was basically,
it was almost a reef,
a reaffirmation more than anything.
It was,
it was like,
oh,
I remember this.
Like I hadn't done it in about a year
and a half to two years.
And then,
uh,
we all,
we did dmt three or four times.
We did like a a trip and then we went
back in,
went back in again.
I can't remember his three or four
times,
but it was.
It just made me realize like,
oh yeah,
okay,
this.
This is just the though the world that
you're living in is like a thin veneer
over this gigantic,
impossible realm of souls of love and
expectation and and understanding and
information and that that's what the
universe is made of and that you're sort
of trapped in this very strange,
rudimentary,
tactile existence where you can pick
things up and put them on scales and you
can measure things with a ruler,
but the rest of the universe is not made
of that stuff.
The rest of the universe is made out of
ideas.
thoughts and there's dimensions that you
you can't travel to with your feet and
with a car,
with a plane,
like there's portals that you go through
and these portals of chemical portals
and your brain literally is wired for
these.
Not only that,
your brain produces dimethyltryptamine,
which is the most potent of all
psychedelics.
It's literally made by the human body
and it's,
it's everywhere.
It's in all sorts of plants,
thousands of plants.
It's in every animal.
It's like all these different creatures
create it.
They have it.
I mean,
in Europe.
It's actually made by your third eye
there.
Pretty sure you know,
there's,
um,
there's a group out of New Mexico called
the Cottonwood Research Foundation,
and they're doing these tests on all
sorts of tests to find out the source of
DMT and they've isolated in the pineal
gland of rats and this is the first time
they've ever shown it in a live rat that
it exists in the pineal gland.
The pineal gland is literally your third
eye,
like that thing from eastern mysticism
like this right here,
this little audio here and reptiles,
that actually is a retina in the lens.
It's a,
it's an eyeball,
and this is in the Egyptian would call
it the seed of the soul.
And this one spot in your head is
producing the most potent psychedelic
chemical known to man as well as it's
produced by your liver and your lungs,
like your body's psychedelic chemical
factory.
And this one psychedelic chemicals,
they believe,
and there's been some recent research,
there was a recent paper that was put
out that showed that they think that
during periods of extreme stress,
like would periods if your body body's
convinced that you might be dying or
that there's something happening that
you may be releasing this psychedelic
chemical,
so it might be the portal to the
afterlife,
like it might be the way that carries
your consciousness through to the next
dimension when your body passes for
this,
when you're in distress,
because it feels like it's getting ready
to watch your,
your mom.
But yeah,
your body's like,
this might be it,
this might be it.
Here we go.
Let's.
They think that's the source of near
death experiences.
When people have these phenomenal loving
experiences where they crossover to the
other side,
then they come back and they think that
this.
And you know when,
the way the way people describe it,
that's another issue with psychedelic
drugs.
It's impossible.
Describe.
So when you describe it,
it's so crude,
like the words,
the way I've described it,
as I say,
it's you.
You enter into another dimension filled
with complex geometric patterns that are
made out of love and understanding that
that's what it takes,
but it's still.
It's a bunch of words.
It's like a nonsense thing to describe,
but when you will,
you talked to these people that have had
near death experiences.
They all feel relieved in some sort of a
strange way.
They all feel like,
or a lot of them do.
I should say that when it does happen,
if it does happen,
it's going to be okay.
It's going to be okay.
Like there's a thing that happens.
Then you go to this other place where
there's.
There's no shoes,
there's no tables,
there's no electricity in this house,
but it's,
it's made out of whatever the fuck the
world's made out of.
It's made out of the,
the whatever the universe actually has
below the wiring.
Like you lift up the circuit board and
we're like,
Whoa,
you peer behind the green curtain.
So at this point for you,
when you,
when you did it the last time,
it was almost like a tune up of like,
oh yeah,
I remember now seen this before and I
needed to be reminded.
But then how does that.
Sorry if I'm asking questions that
you've probably already answered,
but like how does the next week of your
life after a trip of this,
like how do your,
does your decision making change?
What happened?
It's up
to you,
right?
That's up to you.
It's up to everybody when everyone is
different.
I mean for me it's a,
it was like a big deep breath and it's
like,
oh,
it's going to be okay.
The last time I did like a real serious
psychedelic trip.
I've done a little bit of acid,
a little bit of mushrooms,
but the last time that a serious one was
right before I've filmed triggered and
uh,
it's just,
um,
it just,
it just lets you know,
like,
um,
you know,
just just do your best to try to be nice
and this is nonsense.
This whole thing is nonsense.
You know,
don't concentrate on the fact that in 20
years,
no one's going to want to fuck you,
or you know that your,
your,
your tits gonna fall off or just you're
alive right now.
You're,
you are existing right now in the one of
the craziest experiences that the world
has ever being a human being in 2018 in
the United States of America.
I mean this is a fucking bizarre
pathway.
You're on.
All of us,
every single person listening to this,
if you can listen to this podcast,
you are in the rarest moment in human
history.
You are literally at the cost,
the very peak of this insane merging,
the same merging of technology,
of information,
of understanding,
of expression,
all the stuff that you see,
all the stuff that we're seeing going on
right now socially,
whether it's the me too movement or
whether it is,
um,
know social justice warriors and people
who are woke and crying out,
racist for listening.
All this bubbling up of our culture is
all this recognition of this ability to
communicate this,
this radical new ability to express your
ideas that is being done by some people
that are responsible.
Some people that are very responsible,
but everyone gets a shot and it's just
like youtube comments.
It's fucking chaos.
You know,
Clark culture is youtube comments.
They'll the world is youtube comments.
Our interaction is this unique ability
where anybody can express themselves and
some people have larger signals like you
or like shift fear or like you know,
fill in the blank.
Anybody who has a podcast,
they have a larger signal and you know,
you have a youtube video that's a larger
signaling of a comedy central show
that's a larger signal,
but everyone has a signal and everyone's
fighting for relevance and everyone's
fighting for attention and acceptance
and there they're fighting for their own
significance.
They just want to exist and they're
yelling out and sometimes the yelling
out like a baby and sometimes the
yelling out like a wise person on the
mountain who has some new information
and it's all happening at the same time.
And it's all just and we're sorting it
out like in some things don't stick like
this whole,
if you're having sex and you're
drinking,
you're a rapist like that didn't stick.
But some of them do stay.
Some of them you can't say retarded
anymore.
That one's sticking,
right?
Like,
and people are realizing there's certain
things that you can do and certain
things you can't do.
Certain things we accept certain things
we can't accept anymore and we're
figuring it out and we're figuring it
out in real time,
in a,
at a radical pace that's never existed
before in human history where something
that was acceptable just 10,
15 years ago is completely unacceptable
now that's.
There's never been a time like that
before.
Never been a time in the entire world
since people started talking.
There's never been a time where change
is taking place at such a radical pace
and you're a part of it and I'm a part
of it and everyone is listening to this
as a part of it.
We're all together in this and no one
knows where the fuck is going.
I love that you're.
You're saying that the reason all this
is happening right now is because we are
now,
we're just communicating at a more rapid
pace.
That's all it boils down to.
You're absolutely right.
It's the communication revolution.
Yeah.
And if so,
if someone says,
you know,
hey,
you,
what?
Were you sad?
It doesn't make sense.
Like,
yeah,
for sure.
No one's going to get it right.
No one's going to get it right all the
time,
like no one does.
No,
I'm not an oracle fucking human.
I was born in New Jersey.
No one's getting this right,
but you are being held to that standard.
We all are now something.
What's good?
There's good to that too.
The good is you realize like when you're
responsible,
like if you make a mistake or you say
something incorrect or you say something
mean,
they were just trying to be funny.
It came out bad.
The,
the blow back,
let's you know,
this is how people feel about that and
it's disproportionate because your
signals disproportionate.
The,
your ability to express yourself as
disproportionate.
So the blow back is going to be
disproportion as well.
So it feels awful,
but that's just an affirmation,
just letting you know,
okay,
this is not what p and,
and sometimes people are completely
wrong about like,
you know,
white girls can't wear hoop earrings.
It's cultural appropriation.
There's,
there's bad signals out there because a
lot of bad signals,
you know,
where you're racist if you wear a
Kimono,
just a of like really dumb bad signals.
But there's also a lot of exchange and
it'll all work itself out.
We just have to be really careful.
We don't lynch a lot of people along the
way,
like the wood that we don't get
convinced that our ideas are 100 percent
the way things should be and that we
listened to all these various ideas,
whether it's ideas about trans people or
gay people or women or men or anybody,
you know,
like it's,
it's like it's super important now that
people think before they act and that
they think before they cast judgment
that we have to communicate because
there's things are fucking flying at us.
Like fish coming down a river and trying
to catch them with your hands.
And there's this too many of them.
Do you,
I mean,
you're broadcasting every single day for
hours.
Do you say things sometimes that come
back?
I mean,
I know you say things that come back to
haunt you or you said this and that was
wrong,
that you said that,
and this is why you're wrong.
Do you,
do you ever catch yourself and go,
oh yeah,
I shouldn't have said that all time.
What do you do with that?
That's of I made a mistake.
I,
I misspoke.
Right?
But not.
This was not an oracle.
If you keep talking,
people go,
oh,
I get it.
Nikki's just the person that says things
sometimes what you don't mean to say
dumb things,
but you're like being a human being.
It's just a flawed exercise.
Like we're super flawed and we're
working with language,
which is like a really awkward way to
express intent.
You know,
it's awkward.
This is sometimes the right.
Yeah.
Sometimes the right word is not there
for you and you use a lot of likes and
um,
so it's like,
like a,
like a and people like,
like what?
People are listening,
they're on the fucking stair climber and
they'll go,
you shut the fuck up,
you talk too much,
you complain too much,
and you know their signal like they're
mad that they don't have a signal,
so they're fucking screaming at you for
your flawed signal.
Do you have a responsibility?
You know,
there's a lot going
on.
There's a lot going on.
There is and yeah,
I mean I have,
I have a radio show every day that I do
and I do podcast and even sitting here
now I'm like,
oh,
what am I going to regret saying?
And I've just gotten to a point where
it's like,
I will apologize if I say something
stupid and wrong and offend someone and
I really feel bad about it,
but like I have to lead from a place of
guidance at this point in my life.
I know I'm a good person.
I don't think I'm a secret psychopath,
which I think a lot of us are always
like,
am I a bad person?
Deep down,
do you ever have that fee?
Did you use to have that feeling where
you're like,
people are going to figure out that I'm
a fucking psychopath?
You know what?
I really wish that I was like Tony
Danza.
Tony Danza was always smiling and he was
always nice to people.
I was like,
I want to kill everybody,
and Tony Danza is also nice and smiling.
I just want to fucking smash people and
Tony Danza just seems like such a nice
guy.
Like God,
I wish I was like Tony Danza.
I used to think that when I was like 19
years old,
I can tell.
I totally relate to that.
I see people and I go,
why can't I just be like her and just
smiling,
smiling and say funny,
nice things that don't offend anyone but
also everyone likes what you say and it
still gets people jazzed up,
but you're not offending anyone.
It doesn't feel good to offend people.
And I say things all the time that do,
and I'm not going to stop because I
just,
I can't,
but you're offending people but also
making a large amount laugh.
Know the problem is the.
If you have 100 people in the room and
10 of them get offended,
90 of them are fucking slap in the table
and laughing their ass off.
That's.
You got to accept that.
That's just part of the game.
That's part of the game.
You and I play.
We play a strange game.
We're in one of the weirdest businesses
ever.
We're in the business of talking shit.
We're shit.
I love it.
I love talking shop and I can't stop.
Right.
Do you get,
do you get in trouble talking shit like
di Di do you feel?
Because I feel like sometimes when I
talk shit about people,
it's obviously I'm just,
I'm talking about myself and I'm,
I'm just projecting like,
oh she's,
you know what?
I'm really talking shit backstage where
I don't think anyone will ever tell this
to anyone.
Right.
It's not a,
it's supposed to be like not a good
thing to do is talk shit.
Like that's not healthy for hands on,
but I love it.
It's fun.
It's a hobby.
You're making fun of things.
You're making fun of things and it makes
sense.
If you're talking shit and it doesn't
make any sense and no one wants to talk
shit with you,
but if you go to Nicky and Nicky said
some hilarious,
that's all your soldier,
that's fun and when you see both,
hate someone together and you could just
send each other snap screenshots of
their instagram and be like,
look how sad this bitches when really
I'm just seeing myself in her
sometimes when you're saying oftentimes
what you absolutely hope you never are,
yes,
but that you fear that you are and you
think you might be.
So it's,
it's,
it's me hating a tiny piece of myself
that I'm trying so hard to keep it at
bay will be parent or sad or you're
hating me.
Human behavior.
That's flawed.
That's where you're heading.
Yeah,
because I don't want to be flawed and
I'm secretly feeling flawed because I am
flawed because we all are,
but it's part of.
It's a way to
forest that.
You'll never going to do that again,
but talking shit about people that are
doing
hold yourself accountable because then
you can't talk shit if you do it.
So it keeps you in check.
That's a really good point.
So it's good to do.
Yeah.
There's some group text messages.
I know you mean my God,
where are you only talk about one person
in that we only go to that mass text to
talk shit about that one person.
Oh,
have you ever talked.
Have you ever sent a text to someone
that you were talking shit like shit
about the person?
No,
but it happens.
There are stories of people sending.
Like this one girl the other day told me
like in a makeup chair,
she was like,
oh,
I want sent someone a text about someone
at work that we are currently working
with.
That was like Buffalo.
Buffalo is a fat piece of shit today.
Kimberly.
She would wear that dress like that
specific to her and she was working with
her and had to work with her the rest of
the day.
It happens all the time.
Just slipped up,
send it to the wrong person.
Is telling you,
Joe,
be careful because we're all capable of
when you write that name,
when you're writing a name and a text,
it's so easy to just.
That person is probably in your phone
too to send it to them.
It's totally possible.
But yeah,
I,
I love talking to you.
I think that is a thing comics have in
common and you know,
when I extend making fun of things that
I'm getting shit talked about me because
it has to happen.
If I'm talking to this much shit,
people are talking shit about me and I
accept it and it's fine.
I don't want to ever know.
I hate when people go,
Oh,
you know what?
Someone was talking about you and why
would you tell me that?
Be Nice.
Well,
if you overhear something,
keep that in that thing.
Well,
unless
person's like a really good friend and
then you find out that they're
backstabbing you.
You want to know that?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They're saying things to a guy you're
dating.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
if that.
Oh God,
that's the dirtiest of dirty.
When you find out for a guy,
when you find out that a friend of yours
is talking shit about you to a girl,
you're dating.
Oh,
and that happens a lot because guys that
I've had that happen to me with guys
where it's like,
watch out for this guy.
I'm like,
aren't you best friends?
That's a dirty man.
That's a good person.
Yeah.
Me and my friends,
we have a very strict policy of what we
call jihadi,
which means like if you're around a girl
that the guy likes you blow him up to
her,
say,
oh,
he's the best guys.
Awesome.
I love that guy.
As long as he is.
And if he's not,
it shouldn't be friends with them
anyway,
but as long as he is,
you let him know,
like,
you know,
fill in the blank.
Mike is just a fucking phenomenal guy.
He's,
he's such a good dude all the time.
Like he loves you too.
Says great things about it.
I'm already into this guy that you're
talking about in this example.
I'm like,
yes.
dude,
when I was around,
you know,
whatever,
shelly.
I was like,
boom,
I blew out my friend Eddie Bravo came up
with that term because I would do that.
He goes,
dude,
you totally jihad at me for that girl.
That's what we're doing.
You just blow you up.
Let everybody know.
Knows guy's awesome.
He's the best.
I do that a lot.
It feels good too.
It feels the opposite of talking shit
if you're not lying.
Yeah.
It makes us more in that line as long as
you're not lying.
I love that.
Yeah,
but,
but it's hard.
You know,
the,
the petty instinct is to talk shit.
That's the petty instincts.
Some people deserve it and some people
don't.
You know,
it's,
there's different motivations,
right?
Like sometimes you talk and shit because
you're really jealous of someone.
You're jealous of their effort,
their work ethic,
their success,
the way they look.
What a,
what,
fill in the blank.
You're jealous of something about them.
That's generally for me,
root of that.
If I'm going to be honest,
I,
I recently got busted talking shit about
someone and I told and she,
it got back to me from another friend
and I wrote their own,
I go,
I'm jealous of you.
You're cool and you're who I want to be
and I want to be friends with you and
you didn't seem to want to be friends
with me.
So I decided I hated you and that you
weren't to be trusted.
And I told people that and it wasn't
true.
It completely wasn't true.
As threatened by you and you're hot and
I don't like that you exist in the same
business as me and it makes me jealous.
And what did she say?
And she said,
I totally get that.
And I,
at first she goes,
at first she just thumbs down my
apology,
which I loved.
And then I was like,
we're going to be good.
But I,
I love good.
I love apologizing.
I love,
like admitting when I've been jealous or
petty and I will continue to do so.
But if I'm caught I'm just,
I can be.
So it got back to me that I said about
this girl that she shouldn't be trusted
and I go,
I don't even know why I would say that
about her.
I have no evidence to back that up
equals I was just petty and jealous in
that moment.
So I wrote her.
I was like,
dude,
I don't know what was going through my
mind that week.
But yeah,
I did say that about you because
standard,
it's a standard instinct.
It's a standard emotion.
So common.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and as a woman in this business,
like I just,
I support women's so much,
but I'm aware of every woman who is a
who was doing the same thing I'm doing
in this book,
like I'm aware who are the up and comers
and I'd take them under my wing and I
build them up.
But I'm like,
I'm aware of like there's a part of me
that's like crazy deep breath.
That was me seeing a headline of them on
deadline.
He's just like,
I know have a new show.
I know that it's good for all of us.
We have a new show and it's in the slot
that your show was in.
You know what it is.
I literally have to unfollow girls
sometimes who I'm friends with who are
in,
who are comedians,
who are my peers and who I respect and
think they're funny.
I have to unfollow them if I see that
they're just like,
I'm working a lot right now and they're
putting it out there that they're like
really busy with work and I just got
kicked off dancing with the stars.
I have to unfollow them because I start
to feel sad about myself and I would
rather just remove that from my feed
then and then it's a really awkward
follow when I know that or they messaged
me on one of those things and they see
I'm not following them because it's like
we all know we follow each other.
They know and sometimes I'll just tell
them I've unfollowed you because you,
you make me feel sad about my own career
over that.
It's easier to just take them out of my
feed.
Yeah,
but that's a weird one.
I am looking to get over it.
I am,
I am
just just use it as informal as
inspiration.
Use them as fuel to work harder.
Yeah,
I do.
But I would also like to not see their
tour dates scheduled.
Crazy.
That one go.
That's not a good one to accept.
I don't think,
you know what I probably,
I'm probably going to unfollow one.
All,
all you guys with your,
with your workouts and your calorie
counts that you post mad shit.
But I'd even post the big one.
I didn't triggering as fuck to people
who are like,
you know,
hate their bodies and stuff.
It can be very triggering.
So like when I see girls,
they're like,
I just ran a marathon.
I'm like unfollow,
I can't,
I can't have you in my life bragging
about this shit.
Listen,
I go to the gym too and I don't tweet
about it.
I want to.
I just so many calories but I don't
tweet tweet about it because I don't
want to trigger people and I don't want
to be the.
I don't want to be what I am so jealous
of,
but I should brag about it.
And I also liked that some people are
like,
look at what I did at the gym.
Fuck you.
I'd worked today.
And they're proud of themselves,
but I can't.
I can't see.
I get inspired.
Okay.
Do you know who I go to?
Like all the time for inspiration?
The Rock.
That motherfucker never stops.
He never stops.
I mean,
I don't want to do what he's doing.
I don't want to do these movies.
I don't want to do what he's doing,
but that I fucking admire the shit out
of that guy's work ethic.
That guy.
I'll fly to Tokyo,
it will be 4:00
in the morning.
He sets up an elliptical machine,
starts going after it.
That's what he does.
And that doesn't make.
That doesn't put you in a place of like,
I'm,
I'm never,
I can't do that because you can.
But the thing is,
Joe Rogan,
you can do that.
Look at that.
Look at all his food and he gets to do
that.
Oh God.
He landed in London,
midnight ordered Sushi like a
motherfucker go to.
Is His instagram with all of
this is you are the Rock Joe.
You are the Rock,
you do these workouts all the time and
that's how you get that shirt.
Rock.
I got to text x
today from David Goggins and I told
David Goggins I'm trying to beat
everyone by double.
He's like,
fucking kill it.
Like capital 100 exclamation points.
That's what I'm saying.
Look at that dude focused.
I see that I want to go work out right
now.
Are you insecure about anything right
now in your life?
Well,
people are always insecure,
you know,
I mean there's not something that's
like,
well,
I'm always insecure about my act.
I'm always working on it,
you know,
I'm always trying to pick it apart and
look at it like,
like someone who hates it.
I'm always trying to like where's the
flaws?
You know?
And always trying.
I heard you talking about that the other
day of like,
now that you've done your specialists
out and like watching it,
now you come up with new tags.
Oh God
always,
always.
But that's so because you're always
growing and learning and getting better.
And I think comedy is like a living
thing.
It's like as a live you keep watering
and it keeps growing,
you know,
and sometimes you have to trim things to
make it better.
Just like a Bush,
you know,
Trim a little here,
trimodal there,
it gets fuller,
you know,
there's,
but then also grows and gets bigger,
you know,
but then you got to release it at a
certain point in time.
My,
my,
my schedule seems to be two years,
it seems to be.
I develop a full solid hour and a year
and then I hammered that motherfucker
like a Samurai sword for the next eight
months and then I film it and then four
months later it airs and then I start
credit card ashy and bet in the new
specialists in the last one.
The last one that's triggered.
That one was.
So I've seen that your stuff is,
but how do you write,
like do you,
do you literally write right or.
Oh right,
right.
Yeah.
I'll show you how right.
Use One of the things that I use,
I've been using over the last couple of
years.
I always write like in Microsoft word
and shit like that,
but I use this program called scrivener
that I really like and the reason why I
really like it,
especially when I'm doing new stuff is
the way it's set up.
Like if you,
uh,
was this,
oh wait,
I know the bed that is in the new one
that I love that you've just done the
women inventing things.
Oh my God.
That bit I saw that grow.
That was a devastating bit because the
first time I saw it it was like already
like one of those bits.
Where are you as a comedian?
You Watch and you just go,
I can't.
What am I doing?
One of those,
you know,
we've all,
we've all been in the back of the room
going,
what am I doing?
If that's what's happening?
And then I,
that was like early stages of that bit
and then it became something so much
more.
I haven't seen your special yet.
I'm excited to see where it landed,
but that wasn't an,
that's an incredible bed.
But where does that start for you?
So this is what this in Scrivener,
if you see here,
like all on this,
this is all my new stuff.
So these are all the categories and I
click on each category and when I go to
each category I have all the material
that I've written out about each side.
End caps was,
it's not cool to kick robot.
Do you know what that's about?
Peta?
Peta released a statement because Boston
dynamics
has created these robots that are self
balancing.
So they have like a gyroscope in them.
So these scientists were kicking these
robots,
these four legged robots and Peta
released a statement saying that it's
not cool to kick robots.
Yes,
this,
this.
They did.
I'm like,
you fucking weak pussies.
This is going to be problem number one.
When the robots take over these fucking
people are gonna.
They're gonna open up the door.
Like you know,
robots are alive and they're,
they're sentient and you can't kick
them.
You know they're going to eat your
family fuck.
And the same point in time,
you know,
they're coming up with these,
more and more advanced artificial
intelligence.
So this is how right write.
So these,
this is essentially stage two.
So Stage one is,
you know,
I do everything in Microsoft word,
so this is in Microsoft word.
All of these are.
And it's just like you just loose
thoughts.
You're not really editing as you go.
Okay.
Exactly.
So like
this,
which one is this?
This one is um,
this is a lot.
Yeah,
I write you gotta write.
This is how I think.
I think.
I think you've got to do two things.
You got to Ad Lib,
you got to do it on stage,
you got to work things out on stage.
But I think you're foolish to not write
as well because I think there's so much
to be gained by sitting in front of a
computer working on your act.
That's one step.
Another step is you have to review your
act.
You have to listen to it or watch it.
Preferably watch it.
Like I learned a lot watching the
editing when I was editing this special
and I snapped.
I had a snip,
I decided I wanted to be an hour and my
set was like an hour and 17 minutes,
so I said let me just cut,
just,
I just want it to just fuck it.
Boom,
just one hour,
boom and done.
So I had caught a couple of bits out,
but when I did that I was like watching
the videos.
Like,
you know what?
I should really videotape everything.
I should watch the video because it's so
much more immersive than just audio.
You.
You only get so much out of audio.
I kind of know my expressions,
all the different things that I'm doing,
but when I see them I go,
oh,
it's better if I move like this or it's
better if I pause there.
It's better if I raise my eyebrows.
It's better if I look concerned.
Don't realize how much of comedy is the
physical thing until you do watch it.
You're so right and,
and you're right about writing it down.
Anytime.
I've had to do a transcript because I
don't write anything down Longhand,
but when I've had to do a transcript for
tonight show or like just for laughs
festival and see it.
Then you start writing new tags and
you're like,
all this took was for me to write it
out,
but then what do you do for Microsoft
word?
Then you take it to take it to that
scrivener and then what do you do there?
I
put it.
I'd take the stuff from Microsoft word
and then I trim it down and when I trim
it down I put it in Scribnar and when I
trim it down and put it in Scribnar,
what I'm essentially doing is saying,
okay,
this is ready,
this is ready to play,
and then what it's scrivener do.
Oh Shit.
I left my notebook in a hotel room.
God Damn it.
Someone's going to freak out.
So then from there I write things out on
an actual notebook and the actual
notebook is basically just to get my set
list in order and to make sure I
highlight all the different tags.
So there's three stages.
There's the Microsoft word stage,
which is basically just free form free
association writing things down.
No,
there's no structure to it.
Sometimes it comes out like a bit.
Sometimes it's just nonsense that never
goes anywhere.
Okay.
You needed to get out anyway so you
could get to others.
Yeah.
You will.
You just urging.
Yeah,
well it's.
I don't know if you need it,
but it's like there's a road and get
onto and as you're on that road all of a
sudden like,
oh look,
I found a bag of gold and,
and you don't find that bag of gold.
If you stay home,
you gotta walk,
you gotTa get out there and that's,
that's what the writing does with the
writing does it allows you to pick up
these little bags of gold along the way.
And then I'd take these little bags of
gold when I pile them up and then I
throw them into the fortress and the
fortress is like scrivener,
so then I can move those bits around
like what is it?
Why is that different than Microsoft
word?
The reason why it's different is because
it's set up in columns,
right?
So you see how uh,
and it's also as corkboard see Jamie's
got it up on the big screen.
So when the court records see how it's
set up right here,
like each one of these things,
if you go to the left side here,
each one of these categories I can move
and I can,
I can change,
I can have that bit in the beginning and
then once I'm in the bit I could also go
to this and that sets me up with a cork
board so I can have like,
I could set up little note,
like little a setlists.
Well like that,
like up there little notepad things.
So I can write down these on these index
cards.
Like don't forget this or this is
important here or this tagline,
huge try switching this around and
it's just this constant.
But are you already like this or you
already this kind of an organized
person.
Have you always been this way or did you
get.
You have to know this is a discipline
thing that if you can teach yourself to
be like that,
because I just feel like some people are
made that way.
This is not me.
No,
no,
not like this at all.
This is just look at your backpack.
You just brought out in every pocket as
a thing and a pen as just cleaned it up.
No,
you're like that.
no,
no.
If you caught that three days ago,
he's fucking.
Wires are coming out.
Are like chaos and domestic guns really.
That makes me and so many people
listening feel so good right now.
I cleaned it up a lot,
but a lot of times your house,
like,
I mean I know you probably have people
come in and clean,
but like if you're in a hotel room over
the weekend and don't have a maid
service,
what are we looking at?
Chaos.
Everything's spread out all over the
place and you throw it hits the ground
I'm in.
When I'm in a room like a hotel room.
Um,
it's basically like battle camp.
I'm ready to roll.
No,
I'm not going to care what it looks
like.
You know,
I'm here like I'm want a clear path to
the shower.
You know,
I,
I have a desk.
As soon as I get into the hotel room,
I set the computer down the desk,
I plug it in,
get connected to the Wifi and then I,
you know,
it depends on how long I'm there for
what I'm,
what I'm going to do and then you know,
I get to work,
you know,
if I'm there,
I'm there to work.
So that's.
I set everything up,
spent time folding shirts and socks and
shit and put different things in
compartments.
No full shit.
I also buy these shirts.
There's a company that I work with
called Mizzen and main and they make
these shirts that are like Super Flexi.
I'm going to have you ever seen me wear,
wear these shirts on stage?
I wore it on my last special special.
They're like pajamas there.
You pull on them and they have a flex to
them so they don't feel like anything
and they never get wrinkly.
So I could roll that bitch up in a ball,
throw it into the suitcase and then pull
it out and wear it and you would never
know.
Efficient.
But it's just,
they're the best to wear because when
you're on stage they don't feel like
anything.
They feel like you're wearing nothing.
What is this again?
Ms Dot and main.
Is the name of the competition?
Do they make women's stuff?
That's a good question.
I do not know find out.
So I wear them and I wear these jeans
that have like flex to them.
So the genes are like pajamas too.
Like the jeans,
they're literally like sweatpants,
like you pull them,
they snap so they don't get wrinkly
either.
And what's your like,
like your regimen,
like your,
your skincare regimen.
Do you spend a lot of time on that stuff
before you go to bed?
Are you washing your face?
Are you applying oils and creams?
Like are you.
Yeah.
But you don't attend a lot of times you
don't waste a lot of time doing stuff
that doesn't.
You're very utilitarian.
But like not just botox.
If that's you mean I'm a man?
No,
I don't think.
I definitely don't think you look like
your best self.
Like I'm saying like you literally see
major list to me.
I don't understand you like,
but it is interesting to me because I
would have thought you were very
meticulous with like organization and
wasted a lot of time organizing things
and I like that you don't.
Oh No,
no,
no.
I think you have to have both.
There has to be.
Look if you're a comic,
right?
If you're good.
Especially I think there's a certain
amount of you that has to be impulsive.
It has to be reckless and impulsive and
you have to be like one move away from
ruining your life all the time,
but you have to keep it under control.
It's like you have a wolf and you have
it behind like this flimsy chain link
fence that you just like,
oh,
I'm going to wire this fucking shot and
I'm going to go to work and I hope the
wolf doesn't get out.
That's literally what it's got to be
like.
But then you also have to have
discipline and I think those two
counterbalance each other and one of the
things that's helped my act tremendously
over the last few years.
I think my,
my I think triggered was my best special
ever and I think this one is better than
that.
I think strange times better than
triggered.
And one of the things that over the last
three or four years that have really
concentrate on is this process.
The process of organizing and being very
meticulous about like how I structure
my material and then doing a lot of sets
too.
You got to do that and then fuck around
and go on stage.
Trump,
I'd like to go on stage high.
I like to fuck around because those are
workout sets in,
in,
in those moments of chaos.
Sometimes a thing will come out that
wasn't there before.
It just popped out of nowhere.
And that motherfucker might be my.
That might be my Bruce Jenner bit,
that might be my closing bit in those
bits are.
They're rare,
they're strange,
they're theory theorial.
They come out of the sky.
You don't know where they're from.
And you have to nurture that and that
comes from chaos and that come that this
is not necessarily a discipline thing.
So there's the creativity in the madness
has to sort of,
they have to share space with the
discipline they have to,
they have to go back and forth with each
other.
So we've always thought like,
like people have always thought of
Comedians as being like sad people are,
drunks are messy,
people are not disciplined,
don't have their shit together.
But why I don't think that's the case.
Like I'm always going to be fucked up.
Right.
Okay.
So how about I be fucked up,
but I also keep it together,
you know,
so I always have these thoughts,
like I still have crazy thoughts.
Like what?
Like what's your,
what are you,
why are you fucked up?
Like what are you,
what's your fucked up thoughts for?
Probably definitely have brain damage
will probably definitely have like some
sort of head trauma induced damage.
I don't know what's going on.
Does that manifest itself?
I don't know.
I'm sure sometimes.
Yeah,
really not totally like that,
but also I work out so much that I drain
all that shit out of my system.
You meditate,
right?
Yes.
I spent a lot of time doing the float
tank too.
I have a float tank right here.
That helps a lot.
Um,
but I think that if I did slow down and
you know,
and people are like,
oh,
you're fucking work so much because
you're afraid you're crazy.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
What do you say,
Samsung?
Only when I'm running I'm like,
you're running.
I'm forrest gump and right now I can,
when I'm going through the worst times
of my life,
I could just run forever.
And that's what,
when you see old men running and you're
like,
what are you,
why are you running from your running
from something ever when you work out
that much,
you're running from something and mit to
it.
It's a,
it's a great copay.
It's better than drinking for me.
Well it,
it,
but it works.
That's the thing.
It does.
Yeah.
Like if you are crazy and you do it,
like if you're a comedian,
guests what?
You're fucking crazy.
If you're a good one.
I've never met a good one.
That's not crazy.
I mean everybody's got their own crazy
like howie mendell.
As crazy as you can't touch people.
You know,
he's got to put paper towels on the
ground every time he walks.
Like when he goes to a hotel room,
you know what he does is he lays out
paper towels,
a pathway to his bathroom,
to the bed.
Again,
he won't touch people's hands.
Severe Germaphobe,
Super Nice Guy.
The nicest guys you'll ever met.
Meet.
That's his crazy.
His craziest different than you're
crazy.
You're crazy.
Is Different than my crazy.
To my crazy different than crystal.
Leah's is crazy.
Everybody's crazy.
I know.
Everyone's so crazy.
To be,
to be good.
You have to be.
You have to embrace that.
There's no way else your coming up with
the kind of fucked up shit that you and
I say onstage that you say in front of a
bunch of people and then you hit it with
a tagline and then take it to another
place like there's no way your normal.
There's no way it's not.
It's not possible,
but are we?
Are we more crazy than the average
person?
Know that's the thing.
We're just going everywhere.
Everyone's fucking crazy.
I bet less crazy than the average person
because we're free to express ourselves.
The average person has to live this
fucking bizarre,
contained life where you show up the
same place everyday.
Do something you don't want to do every
day with a bunch of people you probably
don't even like,
and you're all backstabbing and weird
with each other and you're just doing it
for a paycheck.
You know,
and you're,
you're,
you're spending the majority of your
time here on this heavenly body hurling
through infinity,
doing something you don't want to do.
Yeah,
that's more crazy what you and I are
doing.
At least we're doing something we love.
And then that feeling that you get,
I mean,
I've seen you crush,
right?
You go on stage in the main room and you
fucking crush and you say thank you
goodnight.
And everybody was like,
that is that feeling of making all those
people happy.
Have they?
They went out,
they got babysitters,
they got together,
they dressed up,
they went to dinner,
they got to the comedy store or they
ordered drinks.
They sat down there and you fulfilled
their expectations.
You gave them what they wanted to see
and I've seen you do it.
And that feeling that you get when that
happens,
it's indescribable and drag you,
your 300 people happy.
You made them all laugh.
I mean this,
there's nothing like it on earth for us.
I mean,
don't you see people that never get to
kill and you go,
Oh,
you poor pitch.
Never get it to kill.
He just go through your life as a
doctor.
You never get to kill,
kill.
How do you go through life?
He wanted to die.
I was like on a path to like,
I'll probably just kill myself some day
if I don't find a purpose,
and then killing gave me a purpose,
kill.
Going onstage.
Killing on stage was like,
okay,
now I have a reason to live.
That's like fucked up.
It's fucked up.
It's so fucked up.
But it keeps me going and I and I get to
continue to do it.
It's fucked up some.
It's a struggle to do and that's
exciting.
But don't you like the art of comedy?
Like didn't you'd like it before you
ever did it?
Hell yes.
The greatest.
It's such a good.
Yeah.
I mean,
but it just never seemed like an option
to me.
Like I didn't even like look at stand
ups.
Like,
oh,
that's something I could ever do and
then get anybody does until you do it.
There's some people that are like,
I love what I grew up.
All I did was a memorized comedy and I
performed it for my class and I won't
memorize people stand up.
It was never even something I paid
attention to until people were like,
you should do it,
and I paid attention to it.
I could do routines and Conan and
everything,
but stand up.
I was.
I was never really aware of what w.
What were you,
what was your exposure to it early on?
Well,
when I was about,
I think I was 13 or 14,
my parents took me to see live in the
sunset strip.
Yeah.
It was a in the movie theater and it was
Richard Pryor and it was absolutely the
first time I'd ever seen anything like
that.
Cool parents.
Oh yeah,
hippies.
Yeah,
and that moment when I was in that
audience watching that and in dying
laughing and looking around,
I remember I really,
really distinctly remember looking,
not just looking at the screen,
but looking at all the people that were
just like slapping the chair and moving
around and holding their chest and
thinking how insane is it that this guy
can do this,
that this guy can just talk and just
through talking,
he's,
he's making me laugh way harder than any
movie I'd ever seen in my life.
And I think it came around.
I think that movie came out.
I think live with the census came out
around the same time as stripes,
which is one of my all time favorite
comedies.
But I remember thinking,
why isn't stripes as funny as that guy
talking?
How insane is this thing that this guy
can do where he,
he's just talking stripes.
I'm watching all this stuff play out.
There's texts and yeah,
you know,
and,
but he's funnier than that.
And I remember thinking he's Funnier
than any movie that I've ever seen.
Even in Richard Pryor movie,
uh,
Richard Pryor movie,
like never as funny as him talking like
him talking his way.
Funniest thing,
the funniest thing,
a comic killing.
Like I remember my friend Steve
[inaudible],
he said something about,
uh,
he went to see something about Mary and
this was his instinct strip is his
fucking old school Italian guy.
He's a lawyer.
He was on the Sopranos.
He,
uh,
he said he goes,
it was as good as someone killing.
That's what he said.
He was as good as a comic killing.
That's a funny.
That movie is.
I was like,
wow,
what a crazy statement.
It's as good as a comic killing.
Like it's universally accepted that if
you go to see,
you know,
fill in the blank,
Dave Chappelle,
whoever it is,
it's killing bill burr when they're on
stage smashing that.
That's probably the funniest thing you
could ever experience.
So the art form itself is to me like
it's the craziest
it most craziest dynamic art forum that
we stand up there with a microphone and
talking to it.
And that's all we have.
There are times where I'm on stage,
I'm like,
what,
how,
how are you doing this?
You have that moment that other people
say to you all the time.
It was like,
how do you just,
you know,
musicians say they're like,
I have a guitar and I get to sing and I
rely on all these things use,
have to talk and there's no other option
for us.
Like it's like that's all we've ever
done,
but it is a wild thing that we do.
It is.
But you know,
musicians have their own wildness.
I mean,
could you imagine?
Oh God,
no.
Yeah,
I'd,
no,
because I have no skills.
I don't have it either,
but I admire the shit out of it.
One of the reasons why I admire it
because I don't have it like a watch.
Like I have friends that are musicians.
I go to see them live and it's,
it's so fulfilling to me because I have
no talent.
So like when I,
when I watched them do it,
I was like,
this is amazing that they can do this.
I can't do that.
That's incredible.
Like wow,
when I go to see Cirque du Solei,
I get the same feeling.
Wow.
Doing dancing with the stars.
I'm just like watching these dancers.
Like how did you just do like that?
That took me months to learn and you
just taught it to this girl in three
minutes for her to fill in for me to do
the camera black.
Like it was just like I couldn't get
you.
That is the thing of the wonder of like,
I just can't.
I don't even know what that's like to
do.
But I of course.
Do you play an instrument?
Do you have any musical ability?
None.
Zero.
It was like you would know.
I know.
Doesn't it suck?
Like want that?
You don't want to.
I don't want to learn anything and I do
too much shit already.
Yeah.
You to where you don't need it.
I can't,
I'm trying to manage my time.
I'm just uh,
yeah.
Um,
I'd have to manage my obsessions,
but I think that what we are seeing,
whether it's in music or in,
you know what going to see a great comic
or anything when you're seeing is these,
these portals for expression and the
more they concentrate on that portal for
expression,
whether it's dancing,
whether it's musicians or even someone
making a film,
there's more they concentrate on those
portals of expression.
The better the message and the better
the impact it's going to be for the
people that are enjoying it.
The people that watch it,
and I think Paul Mooney told me that a
long time ago when I was a young comic
coming up and he was like the old sage
at the comedy store.
He goes,
if you really want to get good
accommodate,
you want to go up and kill.
He goes,
you should go get into tained.
Go get entertained.
I go,
really?
He goes,
yeah.
you know what I do?
I go to see some music.
I go to see a movie,
I get entertained,
I get entertained and I want to
entertain.
I was like,
oh,
that makes sense.
Like you go see someone kick ass,
right when you go see someone sing and
it's fucking amazing and you're like,
God that,
that,
that portal for expression,
like they've honed whatever message
that's going to go through that portal
and it reaches you,
you know,
it's the result of hundreds of not
thousands of hours of twisting and
turning and hammering and sculpting and
massaging and sanding,
and then you get to see it in this
finished form.
Like awe inspiring.
Fuck yeah.
Do you go see a lot of music and as much
as I can,
yeah,
I do it on purpose.
Like I try to be entertained on purpose.
Are you saying that to me just now?
It's like that I need to work harder at
doing like it sounds stupid,
but I need to go and enjoy myself and be
entertained more.
You're absolutely right because every
time I do I walk away from it and I go
and be a better comedian.
I
think.
Well,
like I said,
he told me that in the nineties and he's
just such a wise man and when,
when he told me that I remember thinking
like,
God fucking totally completely makes
and I think um,
we don't do enough of that.
And also I think if you just do only
comedy in your round comedy all the
time,
we didn't get too wrapped up in it.
You get to in your own head and you,
it takes away a little bit of your
ability to be free.
Yeah.
I,
I don't,
I don't seek out comedy.
I've seen enough of it,
but movies and I went to a musical last
week at forced myself to go,
just watch people be great at that.
And it was,
I left feeling good.
It's good to do.
It's hard to do though.
Like to watch a movie.
I feel accomplished at the end of it.
Like I read a book,
that's how,
that's where I've gotten to now if it's
a good movie,
you know,
if you see something that's like,
like x mocking.
I was like one of my favorite movies of
all time,
but I remember seeing that movie and
getting out of there going,
God damn it.
I want to make something like that.
Something that when I leave I go,
fuck.
That was good.
God Damn.
They nailed it.
You know like when when something comes
together like that,
I think it gives you just a little bit
of juice.
Music definitely does that to me.
Like I'll play like a five.
There's a song that really cracks with
me.
I'll play that motherfucker on repeat in
the background while I write.
I'll just,
I'll just one song just over and over
again and all the songs sort of like
fades into the background and just gives
you energy.
Once you hear it like two or three
times,
like the words don't mean anything
anymore and then it just becomes like
this fucking this power supply.
Have you done the Goddamn comedy jam?
And like,
Nah,
no interest.
Interesting.
Bill was trying to get me this thing the
other day.
He's like,
you should do it because if I was him
and Dean del Rey,
the what they do is they go to a venue,
like he played the forum last week.
Yeah.
So they get there 2:00,
set up the drums and the guitar and the
amps and then they play to no audience.
They jammed all day.
He played from two to 6:30.
Fat Fun.
Yeah.
They're playing,
they're having fun.
And then you go on later that night and
you know,
you've just free.
Yeah.
I rented a karaoke room for my birthday
and I just sang Taylor swift songs the
whole time and had my friends are held
captive.
They didn't even,
they got the same one or two songs but
we only had it for an hour because I had
to go do sets that night and I just
sang.
I just performed Taylor swift to them
because I want to be Taylor swift and it
was so fun.
I was like,
I should do this more often by myself
just to sing,
to attract and retain and pop star for
an hour.
That is.
So that is such.
That's so cool that they did that.
Yeah.
I think just having funds important
because doing things that are fun,
you know,
like you,
I think you could definitely get too
distracted when you're not concentrating
on what you should be doing,
but I also think you could get too
focused where you lose track of what it
is.
Like what is that?
What do I do for fun anymore?
I've had to ask myself that and I'm
currently asking myself that and like,
what did,
I don't know.
I mean running,
but does that count sometime?
I love it every day.
It's something that,
it's,
that it's a hobby.
Sure.
Why wouldn't account because it's like
you.
Because it's a thing that people are
like,
oh,
I kind of feel like it's a chore kind of
working on is something will look as a
chore.
Yeah.
It isn't any more.
To me,
meditation might be a hobby,
but that's more of a practice that I
like.
It's like brushing my teeth.
So I wouldn't say brushing my teeth as a
hobby.
Um,
no,
and I need more.
But you've always had hobbies has you've
always like martial arts.
Did that turn into a hobby for you as
soon as you started doing comedy or did
you have to like Kinda get back into it?
Not,
never stopped.
It's always been just,
it's almost like a big part of my
philosophy,
like who I am.
It's never stopped because,
you know,
I started working for the UFC in 1997.
That's when I started doing post fight
interviews and I was still very involved
in martial arts then.
That's what I was just starting to learn
Jujitsu.
Uh,
so it was in involved in a new martial
art for me.
And then,
um,
I've never stopped.
I've always done something and I've
never stopped paying attention to it or
studying it or learning new moves or
paying attention to the new trends or
you know,
watching fights or you know,
and especially things that I don't
necessarily practice as much.
I'm interested in that,
like watching different things that
people do.
What's the last hobby you picked up?
Bow Hunting and you're like,
you love it.
Really?
What's a.
to me it's a,
it's,
it's going to sound ridiculous,
but it's a,
it's a spiritual way to achieve your
food,
to get meat and spiritual sounds
ridiculous to people like,
Oh,
you're shooting an Arrow and an animal.
You have to be so finely tuned with your
senses in your skills and your abilities
and there's so much consequence on the
line if you fuck up.
And then the pressure is so immense that
to me it's almost cleansing and its
intensity and that,
uh,
I think doing difficult things makes,
doing other difficult things,
uh,
better.
Not Easier,
but you're get better at it.
You get,
you understand,
like I think if you put yourself in a
situation,
this happens to certain comedians,
they get really good,
they get really famous and then they
only perform for their crowd and they
get soft.
I think we've all seen them.
You've all seen them.
They start to suck.
They start to do,
they're,
they're committing,
their comedy gets soft and they become
like a,
almost like someone doing an impression
of them.
They lose their edge.
And I think one of the ways to keep your
edge is to always be scared.
So always do something that scares the
shit out of you.
Always do something that's nerve
wracking.
Always do something that's difficult.
Whether it's a martial art or it's
learning to dance or learning an
instrument or there's something that's
something hard for bill bird does.
He flies helicopters,
he plays the drums.
I think things like that.
I think those are critical.
I think you need differently and it
almost like she'd be thought of as like
a protocol,
like,
like cross that you're
not just going to do your discipline but
you're also going to be involved in
other,
um,
other disciplines that they add to what
you're doing.
Yeah.
I think that's what you're hitting on.
Exactly why I said Yes to dancing with
the stars,
which dancing is the thing that I'm know
that I'm worst at was because it's like
that's the scariest thing to me.
And if I do that then I can do so many
other things.
And I'm also scared of that.
I'm not as scared of as dancing.
Like it's really weird.
But like I like I'm,
I've talked a lot about sex.
I'm into like,
I want to do weird sex things in my life
that I haven't done.
Like I want to go to sex clubs,
I want to have threesomes.
I've,
I'm pretty vanilla.
Even though my sex club [inaudible] club
is the other people in the sex club
there also there.
Yeah.
No,
that's not the problem for me.
Weirdos chosen on your feet and chill.
They're not.
It's all very consensual and it's all
very.
I just want to study that.
I know enough going in like I'm ready
for it now because I did dancing with
the stars.
I'm like,
oh,
I could go have a threesome,
go to have a threesome 100 percent.
And I was not before because I always
wanted to say I've done a threesome.
I've always wanted that experience to
talk about.
It seems like an interesting thing.
What do you want to do a threesome with
two dudes?
Or do you want to do a threesome with a
girl guy?
I mean,
I would,
I would prefer for my own,
like I would like more dudes than women
because I'm just not like making out in
front of you.
You'd be like,
it has to be about me.
I have to be like,
they have to be mostly into me,
but I can.
I don't mind a little bit of gayness
going on.
Like I don't.
I think we're all very fluid or
whatever,
but good luck with that thought.
I am totally like if a guy has kind of
gay,
but it's like enough end to me,
I'm fine with it.
If you have sex and in your life you
can.
I can tell you I don't care.
Isn't Rni cool?
How many dicks sexual if you like,
equal dicks to pussies.
I don't care as long as you're very into
my pussy while it's in front of you.
Is that rare though?
That seems rare.
It seems like most girls would be
skeeved out.
I think that is rare.
No,
I think it's rare,
but I think it shouldn't be.
I think that why shouldn't it be like
whatever you liked.
Like if you're just in a totally
straight men,
there's nothing wrong with that.
As long as you're not homophobic,
bisexual,
a phobic to the point where you judge
them and you hate them,
but you shouldn't have to like them.
Well,
okay.
Here's,
I don't think that.
I don't think that liking Dick makes you
like pussy any less.
If you also,
if you're bisexual,
it's not like you have an amount of
liking other people's body parts to give
out and you're giving half of that to
Dick's and half of that to put these.
I think you can like them both equally
and be as excited by them in front of
you.
I never met anyone like that.
I've,
I've met bisexual men who like you like
them equally.
I don't really totally believe,
but it was just a good joke that I kind
of believe that I,
I,
I believe in gay women but.
And I believe in bisexual women,
but I think there's two types of gay
men,
I think.
I don't necessarily believe in bisexual
men.
I think there's gay men and then there's
really gullible,
straight dudes who get talked into blow
and crafty gay.
I think that those things do exist real.
There's definitely some gullible,
straight dudes,
but I do think there are really bisexual
men.
I'm just as just a joke.
Of course that's just a joke,
but I do.
I think you're right.
Those do exist like straight men who
have been and who will live with that
secret and I walked around Travolta's
massage therapists
allegedly just to show you a good guy.
Yeah,
I'm into.
I don't,
I,
I think that if I'm not like I don't
look at women and go like,
I want to fuck her,
but if a girl was like super into me,
I could totally date someone and fall in
love with someone and like be in a
romantic,
sexual relationship with a girl.
That would be just as gratifying as with
a man because you would have to be.
So you have to be into me.
Like I think that's the thing that I'm
into.
Men that aren't in a certain way to
certain lesbian,
like a dude energy.
Like I'm arnold energy or is looking for
a woman of energy.
They were like down vests when it's just
a little too warm out for the best.
Yeah.
I kinda lesbians women because they're
just like,
I just like a woman who just lumberjacky
I like to be pursued.
So any kind of energy you give me,
like where you're like I want you and
I'm coming after you and I'm not going
to really take no for an answer.
Not in a rapey way.
We all know,
but like I do like the energy of a sick
woman with a big neck.
I like a feminine looking.
I like anytime a woman,
but I think it's an energy.
But yeah,
like I've met women in rose type
character.
I mean that's.
Everyone's like,
yeah,
that would be nice.
But it's what everyone wants.
No,
I mean Jennifer Aniston is my favorite
part.
Like she is like the hospital.
If she's like,
I know what's wrong with you.
Me.
This is why I can't settle down with a
dude.
Oh God,
yes.
Like Nikki glaser.
Oh my God,
I would you be into that for real?
Wow.
If she was into me,
but if it was like if she was like,
I'm going to try this out,
then no,
but if she was like,
I'm want this girl and I'm going to come
after her.
Oh yeah.
They had a lesbian relationship before?
No,
not even close,
but I didn't make.
I make it.
I made out with most girl.
I mean it was like all my girlfriends
before I ever kissed a guy because I was
so scared of boys that I.
The first time I got drunk I made it
with all of my girlfriends because we
wanted to kiss boys,
but we didn't have boys around who liked
us.
That's the difference in girls and boys.
Guys don't ever do that.
Oh,
they just don't talk about it.
Show.
Oh they do that they
can make out with each other.
I think so.
How many guys,
if you had like 10 guys in a room,
how many guys do you think have made out
with their buddies?
I'm not kidding you.
I think for at a 10 guys have done some
gay stuff early on before they had a
chance to do it with women straight men
who identify as straight.
You are dealing with a severely impaired
sample,
like whatever,
whatever semi homo energy you're
attracting,
these are all the Cymbalta dot put.
Poor John Travolta.
It's just a joke.
Just a joke,
John
the.
I don't think that's the number.
I mean I think it's probably like,
what is the,
what is,
what's the standard accepted number of
homosexuals in a population?
Is it one on one time?
So real.
I think it's like $10.
It would be so many more to stop and
think about that.
Right?
There's 20 million people in Los
Angeles.
You think one out of 10?
I think there's 200,000.
Wait,
no,
that would be like wait,
20 million people.
One that's two.
That's 2 million people.
Okay.
Um,
that is a lot of gates.
A lot of homos.
You could still say homo.
You can definitely still say,
ah,
you fucking homos.
Enjoy it while you can.
Dangerous saying fucking homeless.
It's like there's an aggression to it.
You beautiful home that he can say,
all right,
hey,
respects us.
What are the numbers?
What numbers of gays broken down by?
Yeah,
but how many closeted gays see the
problem that I know so many closeted gay
guys and there's steps.
There's several stages to that.
There's closeted gays that are out to
their friends,
which I have friends that are closeted
gay,
that are out to their friends,
but they're in the business and so
they're closeted,
but then there's closeted even to their
friends.
I have.
I have one friend in particular.
You know who you are,
motherfucker.
No,
sorry.
Okay.
It's a six percent of women or five
percent of women.
Five point one percent of them and three
point nine percent of men that are
identifying.
So then let's round up a little bit.
Yeah.
Well,
how much will we round up?
I got around up at least a percentage of
more.
So we're.
We're dealing with a five percent,
I think five percent.
If you're rounding up five percent,
then we're looking at 10 percent joe.
No,
it's three.
Oh,
what do you mean?
So five percent of women identify in
three point nine percent of men.
So if you're rounding up,
if you're doubling that,
what you're saying,
rounding up five percent or you're
running a five percent of the percent
were both back.
It's been clearly established.
I think,
uh,
you're safe if they're saying it's three
percent,
I think it's probably five percent.
Okay.
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
You're rounding up one percent?
Yes.
Okay.
Then that's what St I think it's about.
Yeah,
probably,
maybe even more because there's such a
stigma whenever there's a stigma to
something is always going to be a bunch
of people that are just in denial of it
and just they're sad that they are,
you know,
a lot of that.
There was a guy that I used to know and
uh,
he was a comic and he used to have the
most ruthlessly homophobic material.
It was awful.
Like he used to do,
like he used to God he to do these
really mean nasty jokes about gay guys.
And then uh,
I moved out here to la and then somebody
said,
hey,
did you hear that guy's gay?
I went,
what?
He goes,
yeah,
he finally came out.
I'm like,
get the fuck Outta here.
And then uh,
go back home,
went back to Boston and then all of a
sudden he's like a big old queen.
It's like he just,
he was just keeping it in the poor
bastard,
you know?
And then that's,
it happens all the time.
The guys,
when guys have acts where I watch on
stage and they're just,
they hate women so much.
That's not so much hating gay people but
hating women in a way that they're like
a lot of guys that um,
I have,
I have a lot.
I used to hate my vagina a lot because I
would hear guys talk about like beef
curtains or voguing Derby's five for $5
and I have like one of those vagina's
right?
So I have like more,
I have like a,
like not like,
it's not like hanging down to my knees,
but like I have a,
I don't have a pussy you see in porn.
Like I like,
I don't want to like a perfect little
designer batch and I used to be really
insecure about it because I used to hear
guys say like too many lips down there,
it's gross and I think that a lot of
guys that have that kind of mentality
about postseason and say that they're
gay and I would be disgusted with pussy
too.
I would have that like,
oh,
it looks like a Rosebud.
I would act that way too if I were a gay
man that if I had to do something that I
didn't really want to be doing by
nature.
So that's where I think that comes from
sometimes being.
So when I see when I see a guy on stage
just say like really disgusting things
about women and just hate women and I'm
just like
gay,
gay.
Yeah.
Do you remember like what I was going to
bring up that.
What is his name?
Ted?
Uh,
we talked about a meal a day on the
podcast.
I used to have a whole bit about them
from ninth,
2009 that my butt's special.
No,
no,
he was the famous preacher,
Ted Haggard,
Ted Haggard who was just fucking rabidly
gay,
turned out he was smoking meth and
having gay sex with prostitutes,
and then the outer did.
I'm on CNN,
the gay prostitute was like,
I suck your Dick,
and we smoked crack together,
and he was like,
but that's what it is.
Like these guys,
they hate what they are and there's so
many of these anti gay politicians that
turned out to begin with so many of
them.
It's almost a go the other way because
you were just telling us who you are and
this is how many times they don't know.
I think the thing about people that are
living a lie is that they're always
living in that lie and they can't see
truth because they're spouting.
I think if you lie all the time,
like you're always not yourself in an
honest way.
You get super confused and you don't
know what it is.
It's like
comics who steal jokes can't write
jokes.
You ever noticed that there's no.
Comics is steal jokes that right.
Amazing.
Right.
Amazing jokes and they don't do both.
Do both.
You do one or the other,
right?
Yeah,
because to be living in that lie like,
Oh yeah,
I thought of that.
That's my joke.
Like you're constantly justifying it and
living in your head like that.
Those comics,
when they're,
when they get out it and they're forced
to write their own material,
they fucking suck.
They suck.
Like,
like a joke,
like an open mic or something.
Like someone who doesn't know how to do
comedy and they could have been doing
comedy for 10,
15 years,
but you'll see their material and
compare it to the jokes they stole.
Wow.
You're so right.
To live a lie that to steel material,
you can't be actually a creative genius
person in another way.
What's a totally different?
It's a different.
You're different.
You're not a comedian.
You're a thief.
You're a magician.
You're doing something,
you're doing,
you're an actor,
you're a liar.
You're a liar.
Not the same thing.
So the opposite.
It's so interesting to take that away
from them and then they'd.
We've seen it.
Yes.
So mentioning names,
we've seen it and when you see it it's
super obvious and they get terrible as
they get older,
as they get further along in their
career,
instead of getting better,
they get
way worse.
It's so weird when you're like,
we've all been accused of stealing
material because there's one tweet that
someone did and it's like,
well that's a similar thought.
And it's like,
well it's a parallel thought.
Idiots.
Like always parallel thought was a joke
theat when I've been accused of stealing
land.
It's like,
why?
So then all of my stuff is stolen
because why would I do that?
Why would it take that one?
Do I really need that that badly that I
would steal it?
And then all this other stuff is
original.
Then all of my stuff is probably stolen.
Right?
And when that some.
One of the weird things that you do find
out when you find out that someone's a
thief,
then then someone starts going through
their material and comparing it to all
these other comedians.
You Holy Shit,
like look at all this,
all my God.
And then look at that time.
It has a bit from mad tv or that's a
cosby bit.
Oh my God,
and then you see like most of their
thoughts,
they've somehow or another pilfered from
someone else and just sort of repackaged
and that's a different kind of talent.
I'm almost like,
okay,
I respect that you were able to have
that room is going for that long.
That's like a different kind of.
You're just a kid imagined that being
that much of a.
just waiting for someone to pull up that
youtube clip,
but they must not.
I don't think they.
I don't think they think about.
They can't possibly think about that.
I mean,
when I used to,
when I used to shoplift,
I was worried about getting caught.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I was addicted.
Shoplift like noses while you're
anorexic.
Big Time.
Oh.
I was like,
I was addicted to it.
I didn't even want it to
keep yourself from about the fact that
you were really skinny.
I was shoplifting to stop from thinking
about how I was hungry or that I was
hated myself for.
It was just a high.
I would get like getting things and I
would steal things that I didn't want,
that I didn't like,
that I would never wear,
that I just wrote this because I could
write.
Yeah.
And I always knew I would get caught and
I knew that I had to get caught to quit,
but I wanted to keep going as long as I
could.
And then I got caught and I never
shoplifted again after getting caught.
But like I remember getting caught and
being like,
I knew I needed to get caught.
Thank you.
Like I'll never do it again.
And she was like,
I'm fucking tired of this shit and
screaming at me.
She was like a couple of years older
than me.
It was an urban outfitters in Lawrence,
Kansas I was on,
was on a break from work and I just went
over to do some light shoplifting and I
got caught on the way out.
The beeper went off.
It was so embarrassing because she went
through my bag and she goes,
really?
The shirt?
This is disgusting.
And she was like cooler than me.
It was so humiliating on every level and
every I was wearing my uniform from my
restaurant job where I worked next door
and it was urban outfitters that was the
only cool place to shop in my college
town and she was like,
your band for three years.
I'm like this,
the rest of college,
so I'd have to go in and disguises to
actually purchase things because that
was banned.
But I,
I never shoplifted again,
but I remember guys,
this is where I would just like wear
sunglasses and a scarf and like Eddie
Murphy when he put on the fast shallow.
Uh,
yeah,
I,
but I,
but being someone who stole things,
like I knew that I would get caught and
I wanted to get caught because it's a
terrible life.
Do you think these people want to get
caught?
No.
No,
I think they just want to kill him.
They get addicted to killing.
You know,
one of the things that happens,
like when someone gets caught stealing
or we're just talking about this the
other day,
was that when someone gets caught
stealing and then you call them on and
they said,
I won't do that again,
and then he's here.
Hey you here.
He just did that your bit at the laugh
factory like that motherfucker.
He said he would stop doing it.
Aren't they?
Get addicted to killing you.
Addicted to it.
Imagine being having that taken away
from you.
That's what I keep thinking about with
comedians that have had,
did not go on stage anymore because
something happens.
Obviously the me too.
Stuff that's happened.
I like,
there's a part of me that's like,
what if someone said I couldn't go on
stage for a year.
Like I was banned.
Like Richard's.
Well yeah,
like forever,
like he's basically been forever.
I don't know what I do if I couldn't do
standup at night and like I'm not
jerking off in front of people.
So like,
I'm not at risk of losing that right
now,
but like I don't think he thought he was
at risk of losing that.
Do you think like it was just a matter
of time?
I mean,
I know that maybe towards the end when
everything was kind of blowing up around
him with other men that he was maybe
worried about it,
but like,
do you think he wouldn't?
Years of like,
I hope this doesn't come back?
Probably.
Yeah.
Because it's um,
you know,
that's a weird one.
That's because that's one that you
liked.
How do you describe that?
I mean,
how do you,
how do you defend that?
Like you really can't.
It's just a weird one.
It's just,
it's not the worst one because I'm into
jerking off in front of women.
I don't know why.
It's my thing.
I'm listening to Jim Norton.
Jim Norton should to.
This is attorney.
He should've done a press conference and
Jim Norton should've been as attorney.
They would have fucking clear that thing
up in a heartbeat.
Jim Norton was said,
well I,
I jerk off in front of women as well,
but a lot of times they have dicks and
that's what I'm into.
And like,
I mean,
yeah,
Norton is so free because he talks about
his,
he,
he hose into trannies and like that.
That's his thing and you know,
a lot of training anymore by the way.
Oh that's right,
that's right thing.
But he can still say it because he's
into them.
It no one even calls him out on it.
They just let it slide.
That's.
He really does.
He does so much for the community.
Yeah.
I don't really know.
I think he's talked about liking having
people shit on him.
Like he puts down a tarp before women
come over sometimes like seven women
piston his mouth.
Remember reading his books like early on
in college and being like,
I can't believe this man talking so
openly about this,
but thank God for him.
There's nothing.
He's not worried about anything coming
back to haunt him.
No.
He's so brave because the fact that he's
so ruthlessly honest like that and loved
for it,
you know,
storm rain,
him talking about blowing another kid
underneath the porch as a kid.
That was,
I mean,
people now talk openly about being
molested or having weird sexual
experiences with boys early on and it's
more of like an okay thing.
When Jim Norton was doing it back in
2002,
no one talked about that shit and it was
an joked about it.
Yeah.
And was beloved by ONA fans for us.
I mean he was someone that early on I
was like,
I,
this is different to me and I love it
and I want to be on the other side of
this where I can talk about all this
stuff too and not,
oh,
that's interesting because there's so
much freedom and being able to be like,
yeah,
I blew a kid under a porch when I was a
kid.
Yeah.
There's nothing wrong with I was a kid.
And being yourself,
being yourself,
being honest.
Yeah.
And you find that when you are yourself,
so as you're not hurting anybody,
you,
when you are yourself,
you find people actually love you for
it.
Yes.
Yeah.
And they love the fact that you can be
so brave that you can talk about all the
different things that you love that
other people might be scared of
admitting.
Yes.
Just like that.
Like his love of transgender women.
Like think of that.
Like if that came out about someone
who's trying to hide that it would be
devastating to them.
But to him it's just like he,
he'll just talk about it openly and
laugh about it,
you know?
And it's not a point of contention at
all.
It's not something he's ashamed of.
It's just who he is.
I know I've,
I've him and there.
There's several other people though,
but just to.
I remember Sarah Silverman or hearing
her talk about being a bed wetter and I
was,
that was like my biggest shame for so
long.
And then I was just like,
oh,
okay,
well then that,
then it's okay.
Just that all it took was one cool woman
to say she did something embarrassing
and I was like,
okay,
it's acceptable now.
Now I can talk about it.
And so that's why I talk about like,
I like anal sex.
I don't think that it's a cool thing.
I'm not saying that like I,
I'm not trying to put that out there as
like nih naughty and don't you want to
fuck me?
Like that's not my intention with it
even though people will put that on me
sometimes,
but it's because you should try it.
It feels good and I want to put it out
there to women.
Like it's,
it actually,
like I want to just more people to
experience it and not be scared of it.
And it is gross and it is scary and it
is weird,
but like I talk openly about it because
I hope that if you are a girl that's
into it,
you're not ashamed of being into it.
Or if you're a guy that's into it,
you're not,
you're going to have a threesome with.
I honestly,
I will listen.
Do you think you would be excited about
a dude but fucking a dude who's fucking
you?
Like have you got some sort of human
centipede thing going?
Um,
no because I don't think he could focus
on me if he was
penetrated himself and it would be more
about taking it for a year in the past.
I think that is so amazing.
I think it's because of you might be the
Dick in my ass.
I'm not sure.
No,
I couldn't stand that.
I would need more focus on trading on
you
two thrusts.
One back be concentrating on both.
Focused on me.
I need to be the focal focal point.
If I'm going to be in one of these
things,
which I think you can arrange that.
Good luck.
Arranging what people are going to focus
on.
Oh,
that's a good point.
But that's,
that's the thing that I was fearing of
doing a threesome is like what if I get
in it and like what if I had to go down
on a girl and like I'm doing it and I'm
like it's bad pussy or something.
Or it's like,
what a bad pussy,
what's bad pussy?
What if,
what if I just don't like pussy,
but what's possible?
When I did dancing with the stars,
I really came out of it being like,
I'm ready to eat some pussy now because
I faced my fear of dancing in front of
millions of people,
which is like the scariest thing I've
ever done on live TV.
Anything go wrong.
And now I'm like,
what's,
why am I so scared of a threesome?
Because I think my thing about
threesomes,
I'm going to get into it and I'm going
to be like,
I don't want to be here and that I'll
still have to go through with it.
But like,
no,
it won't.
What I like,
I changed my mind,
which I do all the time now with
hookups.
I think that as a woman we are so
conditioned to think that men have to
come at the end of it.
There's the thing called blue balls and
like in that if you've,
if you've made out with a guy and gotten
a loan with a guy that and you've
decided to hook up with a guy and you're
like,
I'm getting naked a guy,
you have to go through the whole thing
until he orgasms.
Like that is what,
that is what we are sold because men put
that pressure on you.
It's not men,
it's women,
it's magazines,
it's TV tell you you have to make them
come with like 5,000
ways to blow his mind and to do this
with a feather.
You know,
that kind of keep coming up with those
lists.
I mean,
it's all the same episodes.
How many issues have been made?
I mean it's the same thing with
workouts.
The last ab workout you'll ever need.
Well then you better not tell me another
one because you just said this is the
last one on eight.
Even though you'll say that next year
too.
So there's endless things,
but I.
But my new thing is now,
like when I used to be so scared of
hooking up with guys because I was like,
if I agree to kiss a guy alone in a
room,
then I'm probably agreeing to have sex
with him and then I don't even want to
put myself in that scenario,
so I just didn't even kiss boys.
See,
that's something that a man doesn't have
to fear.
Right.
If a man is alone with a woman and he's
making out with her in a room,
he doesn't think like,
oh my God,
I have to satisfy her.
She's going to be mad at me.
Yeah.
And it,
it,
it's not even about like it is,
it is exactly what you're saying because
I want to backtrack and say it's not
about like he's going to force me to
have sex with them.
It's like he's going to be mad or
disappointed in me and he's just going
like,
he's just going to be mad and I don't
want a guy to be mad at me.
Right.
And so I always had an unpleasant
experience for the other person.
Exactly.
You just don't,
you just want to be nice and
accommodating and that's what I felt
always felt like if,
if I,
if I make out with a guy I have so many
times in my life,
been making out with a guy and been said
in my head like,
what's the least second day to make this
guy come?
Like,
what,
what can I do that is gonna make me feel
the least bad about myself or like
something I,
what do I want to,
what can I do to make what,
how can this guy get off and I can leave
feeling good about myself and like I
didn't do something I didn't want to do.
Which a lot of times you do something
you don't want to do.
It has happened to me.
I do.
I call rape on it.
Do I look back on that guy and go,
he raped me know.
Do you think that the thought I was into
it,
do you think the solution to that is
way,
way longer before you get intimate with
someone?
Like get to know them really well?
No,
I think the solution is educating women
and telling them that it's okay if a guy
doesn't come and it is okay the second
year,
like I'm not really feeling this,
that's the case for sure,
but I mean personally for you to not be
in that situation like no a guy really
well before you're intimate with them
because isn't that part of the problem
is a lot of times people get intimate
with someone,
especially if alcohol's involved.
You get intimate with someone before you
know them and then you may be in the
situation and you're like,
this is not what I wanted and now I feel
gross and I want to get out of here.
Yeah,
I think,
yeah,
that's part of it and to not.
I think it really is though as a woman,
just being able to be,
say,
make the situation uncomfortable by
being like,
I'm done here.
I'm so sorry I'm not going to come and
either so neither are you and maybe
we'll do this again sometime.
I've done that recently,
like the lady who's in charge of the
audition.
Thank you Nikki.
I really reached that point with myself
though.
We're a much.
I did that to someone recently.
I was literally hooking up with them and
I was like,
I just,
I think this is it.
This is going to be like,
and it was,
but here's my thing is like more.
I hate being this woman that,
but if I'm going to get anything across
to your listeners because it's.
I sound like a hack eighties female
comic right now,
but like more foreplay,
like I never thought I'd be a woman that
says that just like we need.
I couldn't always be convinced to have
sex with you.
If I'm willing to make out with you,
then I am what I am.
Somewhere in the realm of things,
and I'm not giving this to every woman,
but for me,
I am willing to take a good decade from
you.
You have that opportunity.
If I'm making out with you.
Yes.
Convince me,
turned me on.
Don't just try to stick your Dick in me
right after making out.
That's not going to be the way to fuck
me.
Sometimes I think I know where she says
no,
why?
They're panicked,
but before she says,
no,
you have all this time to get me to say
yes.
Some people are panickers just we need
to bring back dry humping.
It is so hot to the point where I'm so
revved up that I'm like,
I need it like girls or I want.
Because you know what it feels like to
get fingered when you're not turned on.
It feels like the way it feels when a
girl,
when a girl grabs your deck and you're
not hard,
you know that feeling where you're like,
oh no,
no,
too early.
Don't do it.
Don't do it yet.
Let me just get.
That's the way it feels.
When a guy goes to finger you and you're
not wet,
you're like,
I could get there,
but now I'm not going to because now I'm
insecure that I'm not wet and now it's
like I just want to cut this thing so
don't touch us there until we're like,
please like until we take your hand and
do it.
That is,
if you get us there,
which you will by doing all the other
stuff,
dry humping over the pants stuff,
a feeling.
Our tits kissing,
kissing,
get us revved up and we will ask you to.
We will beg you to fuck us.
You should give a seminar.
I like,
this is like,
you feel that I feel like you're onstage
in front of a large audience telling
people how to do this.
I really,
I could,
I want to give like sex ted talks
because I think that I could get men and
women to have more sex and enjoy it more
because I've just given this stuff so
much thought.
But I,
I really hate being the girl to say
more.
Yeah,
I do.
I talk about this a lot.
I'm just starting to get into this area.
This is,
this seems like it's ripe for material.
Oh Man.
It's,
it's just true.
And,
and um,
I'm also telling guys in the audience
who I might fuck,
like I'm hoping that there's a guy in
the back of the room that I'm into.
You know,
I've done that before where there was a
guy I'm crushing on and I know he's in
the room and I'm like,
here's the.
Just like do some over the pants,
fingering over the pants,
fit jeans,
tight jeans over the pants.
Use the seam on where you're the the,
the,
that little notch.
That's a.
that's a clip thing.
I'm sorry Joe.
Thanks Nikki.
Thanks for being here.
I appreciate it.
We just did three hours.
Sorry to end it like that.
Oh No,
you're fine.
It's fine.
To ended that way.
Keep going if you'd like just to like
settle it down.
No,
we don't need to.
I can,
I can.
I can get off on a high point.
That was good.
It's good to get out there.
I don't need any foreplay on the back
end.
Okay,
so I don't need to rev down.
Okay.
Mickey laser,
everybody.
Oh,
tell everybody where they can find you.
Where can they send these dick pics that
are coming your way?
God,
please don't send any products.
I don't want any dick pics.
I'm on instagram.
Nikki Glaser,
twitter.
Nikki glaser.
I have a Sirius xm show every single
morning,
Monday through Thursday.
You do that from a.
from New York in the Sirius building.
I live in New York City generally.
Yeah.
See you on here so often.
I'm here all the time,
but yeah,
it's every morning from 10 to 12 eastern
on a comedy central radio.
Sirius xm channel 95.
So you have to get up every morning at
10:00
AM.
Yeah,
I know.
That's a good job.
Is a job it.
I love it.
Cool.
It's really fun.
Yeah,
I love it.
This was fun.
I enjoyed it.
Thank you for having me.
I asked you to be on it.
I just confronted you backstage and I
was scared,
but you're awesome and I really
appreciate you having me.
Thank you.
You're awesome too.
It was really fun talking to you.
Nikki Glaser,
buddy.